the next three hours is your chance to
talk with author doctor and former Texas
congressman Ron Paul the three-time
presidential candidate will discuss US
foreign and monetary policy and the
rising popularity of libertarian ideals
the host of the Internet's Ron Paul
channel is the author of several books
including the revolution a manifesto and
the Fed and the school revolution dr.
Ron Paul in your book from 2011 Liberty
defined 50 essential issues that affect
our freedom you write that so-called
moderate politicians who compromise and
seek bipartisanship are the most
dangerous among the entire crew in
Washington compromises too often
synonymous with selling out but it
sounds a lot better it sure does
moderation always sounds good and people
want it and we all want to feel moderate
that we're reasonable people so it does
sell in politics but there's a
difference between moderation where you
sacrifice something you believe and
cooperating with somebody who else who
might have a disagreement but you come
together and you build a coalition for
instance I did quite well with honest
progressive Democrats take a Dennis
Kucinich I did real well with him
because you know we agreed on a lot we
disagreed on a few things we didn't
concentrate on what we disagreed on but
on the things we agreed on you know on
civil liberties and privacy and trade
arguments and war and he he and I got
along very well and like a Ralph Nader
we cut long I get along quite well with
him but he doesn't have to sacrifice and
I don't but if in the conventional
definition of moderation is if I want to
be a true free market person what I have
to do is give up a little bit of free
market and in order to get some
incorporate some but with somebody else
oh I see giving up on the principles a
non-aggression on foreign policy and
also on the protection of civil arey
will have a smaller NSA you know and
will have a little bit of
government intervention will have a
little bit of welfarism it will have the
president fight little Wars but not big
Wars that's why I think it's so
dangerous because you endorse the
principle 100% and I think that is wrong
so you find other people where you can
come together and you build in
coalition's and I think that's where the
answer will be found you know to
cellmate in Washington so when you see
what's going on right now the house the
Senate the president and they all want
to work together but nothing seems to be
getting done what's your I'm not sure
thing I'm suppressing together because
they work together mint of active both
parties agree on the big issues they
don't have any disagreement but they
don't want to work together if they're
looking for power power is a real
struggle people want to have the power
and they want to take care of the
friends so that's a very real issue so I
think the problem in Washington right
now is that it's it's more difficult to
continue to spin you know
okay conservatives like to spend on some
military-industrial project that
probably totally unnecessary Democrats
want to spend on some welfare program
conservatives don't like well when we
were very wealthy and the debt wasn't
outrageous and we didn't have the
problems that we have where we see
bankruptcies of cities and towns and
states it was endless but that has ended
and they're not admitting that the
country is bankrupt so therefore they're
just fighting over a pie that keeps
shrinking and shrinking and this is this
is the real problem but on the big
issues the parties come together on
going to war
let the presidents do it on NSA they
both like an essay on an IRS yes they
arguing politically about the IRS
neither parties going to get rid of the
IRS like I'd like to do so but but the
very big issues they're very much
together the you know when it comes to
some of things on civil liberties like
NSA I mean it were the Republicans any
better than the Democrats no they they
got along together on this and this is
why I think that they we will
admit that not only is the financially
bankrupt but our foreign policy is
bankrupt too because the American people
are sick and tired of it and all you
have to do is look at these last 10
years look at Afghanistan a results in
Iraq and the mess we're creating in
Ukraine it gets tough on and on the
American people know it and they're
saying why don't we come home you know
and die and yet both parties want to
keep all that intervention going and
back to Liberty defined the ethos of
Washington is that the job of the
elected politician is to serve the
company that employs them and that
company is government they are told that
they should serve the system or get
another job very few new politicians can
reject this logic and rationale yeah and
you know I've helped a lot of
individuals get into Congress as being
an incumbent you have a little bit of
ability to help for the most part most
of them didn't do well after week and
after they got there some have done
exceptionally well in recent recent
years but I've always said that I can
tell within a week or so how they're
going to go because the member arrives
he gave one story back at home he got
the support of conservative libertarians
limited government and then all of a
sudden they get in the atmosphere I have
to get on this committee you know and
and and the big pressure is in
Washington to get ahead you got to go
along and you have to be a team player
that's the ultimate argument they use
are you going to be a team player
sacrifice your principles sacrifice
everything you promised back at home
because you're going to be a D team
player and besides you know you could
get kicked off your committee which has
happened you can kicked off your
committee and also they'll say we'll
strike the money from your district
deliberately just line-item veto your
district which is happened to me so it
is a vicious game they play in order for
you to toe the line and most people cave
to a large degree but I would say
there's a couple dozen right now that
are doing a pretty good job of not
jumping in and being
part of the system who are worse I'm not
going to name the names because I might
forget somebody but there's certainly
individuals that I've helped in the past
and it won't be hard to find out when
there's a vote of 400 of 400 to 500 to
the five votes or first two they're
quite a few votes Dennis Kucinich and I
would be the only the only two
individuals voting against some needless
intervention someplace someplace where
they're getting ready to start another
war now you can find out who the people
are that will stick to it and won't Kyle
towel and do exactly as the leadership
tells you to do you know it was was one
time an individuals weren't voting sort
of with with the rebels you know we were
trying to change things in there before
five or six of us he was voting with us
and all of a sudden his voting pattern
changed and I went up to Isis he used to
vote with me on this why aren't you
doing this he's just on his leadership
now he was appointed to something you
know like in a whip team or something
like I he's I'm part of the leadership
so he becomes leaderless you know I mean
he himself believes nothing he becomes a
follower by by joining leadership did
you ever get offered anything no I don't
think so
was it uncomfortable to be you in the
Republican caucus not actually you know
on a social personal basis I probably
have deceived myself a little bit
because I always thought it was fine
because there was not the hostility
nobody argued in fussin and left me
alone they didn't they knew they were
going to change my views so they didn't
come and say do this do this do this we
need you we need you it was just he has
his mind made up we know the lobbyists
never bothered me so leaders in the
leadership knew where I stood but they
loved to have me when I was agreeing
with them because I knew it was based on
a firm principle the Constitution and
they were delighted to have me on their
side under those circumstances
this is from your book in 1991 the wrong
Paul money book and this is again 1991
and here's what you write the cashless
society
is the IRS
total knowledge of and control over the
finances of every single American Ricky
we're still moving in that direction not
a lot of people use cash anymore now a
lot of it is out of convenience and
people get you know sucked into this and
I have to admit that when I see it you
know I used to worry about somebody in
front of the line that was going to use
a credit card today you can pay with the
credit cards faster than you can pay
with cash you know that fumble around
with the cash and getting change and all
they slip that card oh you know you have
to sign under $50 you don't have it so
it's so tempting but it is also a record
it's a record that's kept the government
knows what happens they know where you
go but it's also financial information
government has this information and it's
connected to the big the companies that
collect information but there's a
commercial value to this too but
governments I had a debate probably back
before that I think was in the 80s with
another person who firmly believed in it
his whole motivation was we can raise
more money for the government of course
that's not my goal my goal in life is to
have a government defend individual
liberty not to have more money this is
one reason why I have an argument with
the supply siders who are pretty good on
most issue non taxes and things they
they argue low low tax rate it's fun but
their argument is if you lower the rate
business will pick up and the government
gets more money well that's fine lower
the rates business pick up but reduce
the taxes because we don't want it B to
be the vehicle to raise more taxes
that's that shouldn't be the reason
we're we're in Washington it should be
there to protect Liberty and not to
manage people's lives and not to manage
the economy since you left Congress last
year what are you doing well a few
things you know I continue to write I
have a Ron Paul channel that I work on
almost every day and sent a report into
the Ron Paul channel this morning so I
have a home school program of course I
get some help on that because I'm not
one that's going to design each
individual program
it's a Ron Paul curriculum so I work
with that and the course campaign for
liberty is still very very active and
that's a action group and it's the group
that was able to mobilize a lot of
individuals to get the audit the Fed
bill passed in the house a couple times
and now the American people 80 percent
of the American people agree not with me
on getting rid of the Fed but they agree
with me that the American people deserve
to know who who the CIA is and who they
bailout and who the special interests
are so I'm pretty active and I still go
to college campuses which I really like
I work with young Americans for liberty
who have campus organizations and spoke
with the young Americans of Liberty last
night and I have to admit I enjoy that a
whole lot well your most recent book is
on education the school revolution a new
answer to our broken education system I
want to read a little bit from that have
you expand on it in the leadership
training program I've been developing I
emphasize the following skills first the
ability to think critically second the
willingness to act responsibly taking
full responsibility for your own actions
third a prospective leader needs to know
the basics of communication and this
certainly involves writing it also
involves public speaking fourth is a
system of exercises that help a person
develop real competence competence is
important for Step five self-confidence
someone who is not self confident about
what he believes in or about his ability
to improve his life in terms of what he
believes in will have a difficult time
persuading others and sixth is integrity
there can be no successful leadership if
there is no followership and there will
not be followership in the libertarian
sense if the followers do not trust the
honesty of the leader and I think the
last one of all those the lessons
probably the most important because you
don't accomplish anything else unless
there is a integrity but the the program
is designed to be
self-motivating you have to want to do
it the pier the parents don't have to
sit and do this they is a lot of
self-education they go at their own pace
--is they're encouraged to talk to other
students and there's a lot of writing to
do they have to write you know on a
routine basis and it's a building of
confidence but overall you know there's
a lot of home school programs available
a lot of them are very very good mine is
probably unique and somewhat different
because upfront I say what we're really
motivated to do is teach them about
Liberty teaching them about the freedom
philosophy and so if there's a
homeschooling group over here that's
religiously oriented there's nothing
wrong with that at all mine it isn't
that way it teaches about religious
history but it doesn't it isn't
religiously oriented and I want to
preserve a society where everybody has
freedom to enter into it you know so the
different homeschooling groups would be
legal so it's understanding what a free
market is all about obviously on our
economic courses you're not you're not
going to learn about socialist economics
or KMZ economics and you're not going to
learn about why paper money is superior
to gold money you know these kind of
things so it's very upfront about
teaching a whole system of values and
welcome to book TV on c-span - 48 hours
of nonfiction books and authors every
weekend this is our in-depth program
every month we invite one author to come
on to talk about his or her books this
month
it's former congressman and medical
doctor Ron Paul three-time presidential
candidate as well we're going to put the
numbers up on the screen - A to Z area
code 585 three eight eight zero if you
live in the eastern central time zone
want to participate in our conversation
today five eight five three eight eight
one for those of you in West and the
central to are the mountain Pacific time
zones and if you can't get through on
the phone lines and you still want to
get a comment in to dr. Paul you can do
that via Twitter at book TV is our
twitter handle you can also make a
comment on our Facebook page
facebook.com slash book TV
and finally an email to book TV at
c-span dot a large e will begin taking
those calls in just a minute in those
comments here are some of dr. Paul's
books over the years in 1987 freedom
under siege came out the US Constitution
after 200 years 1991 the Ron Paul money
book a foreign policy of freedom peace
Commerce and honest friendship came out
in a 7 pillars of prosperity Oh 8 the
revolution a manifesto also came out in
8 and the Fed 2009 Liberty defined 50
essential issues that affect our freedom
came out in 2011 and his most recent the
school revolution a new answer for our
broken education system just came out
last year dr. Paul Wendy you and how do
you write you write from your home in
Texas well it's pretty primitive so I
don't know whether I want to tell
everybody when I was in high school I
would I could type very well but then I
got spoiled by my wife and others who
did all my typing I got sloppy so I'm
very slow in the computer but I'm
speeding up so most of this was done
writing out longhand dictating and then
correcting it but I'm much better with a
computer now I can I have a program
where I can dictate into the computer
and then I can do my Corrections and I
do more creative work at the computer so
I'm learning better but a lot of it was
very very tedious you know to write it
out and have somebody type it up and
then you keep keep editing that though I
I don't brag I don't want to teach it
they won't be taught that in my home
schooling they'll know how to type and
use a computer much better than I ever
did well want to go to this email and
this is from Nathan Kelly and he emails
into you would you agree that the best
form of government is none at all or put
another way the only legitimate form of
governance is individual governments
well I'm glad I put the last sentence on
because you always want government who
should be the government the perfect
world if we were all perfect people
would only be self government and our
responsibility would be to ourselves and
that's what my goal is to always move in
that direction today to be a participant
in the debate and say that tomorrow
we're going to get rid of every single
government well if one person doesn't
nobody else that's not going to work but
I think we're moving to the age where
governments are much less important and
I think we should III think that people
are realizing the government's mess up I
think the 20th century was such a
horrible century that we're waking up to
the fact that you can't trust government
you can't trust them the run the economy
you can't trust them to run the monetary
system you can't trust them the run
foreign policy I mean it's just a total
disaster
so I think the least amount of
government is is the best I do not call
myself an anarchist but I think to have
the goal of self-government is a very
very good goal and if you can't have
that then as close to home as possible
and I think that's a natural tendency to
have individuals and family government
local community government and if you
had if you had a free society we
probably wouldn't have a lot more than
that you wouldn't have to and our
founders intended that to be but you
know when they when they went when they
wrote the Constitution and I think they
planted some seeds there that have have
grown to the point where if the
Constitution had worked perfectly we
wouldn't have this monster over here in
Washington anyone exist but all the
regulations and details in taxations and
abuse of the rules and the president
writing laws and bashing the Congress
for not speeding up I'll write an
executive order you know and all this
that wouldn't be true that is the trend
that we have to reverse I'm optimistic
to think that we are changing the views
of a new generation the Millennials are
looking at this and they are seeing what
they're inheriting I think they see a
mess and I think they're very open to
the views of saying yeah
the biggest problem we have is way too
much government to some too much
centralized government and the more self
responsibility and self government have
the better so when you see what's going
on on the border down in your home state
of Texas right now what's the solution
is it's all government created is how
you would correct the government
mistakes it's a mess under our
Constitution our federal government has
some responsibilities but it's a result
our borders are a result of the of the
welfare state welfare at home teaches
people not to work and then we have a
need for workers and people are being
punished in Central America in Mexico
because of there's bad economic system
and there's jobs up here go begging and
people come up and then we and then
those who come they get subsidized they
get free health care and free free
education and so we subsidize the
illegal immigration so it's a real mess
if you had a truly libertarian Society
of free market there would be a great
need for labor and they wouldn't be seen
as the culprits right now I think
illegal immigrants are you know
considered to be you know they're the
really the scapegoats that they cause
all the problem but that's one of the
symptoms of the problems that we have
with government but I I think that
they're obviously there is no easy
solution to it but should we should have
better border control but we should be
more generous and allowing workers to
come in here and more restrictive and
giving out free stuff to people who come
here illegally and then getting them to
vote I mean that part doesn't make any
sense whatsoever
but there was a day not my lifetime when
the work permits were easy in that come
and the workers would come in they'd go
back home and take their money today
even when I was in Congress not too many
years ago I had a lot of constituents
coming we need workers we need them in
the fields we need them on our shrimp
boats and they couldn't get Americans to
work there so but this is all a
consequence of bad management by
government and argument for local
management and self-government when and
how did you develop your philosophy
slowly and steadily but I believe that
all of us are born with an instinct for
freedom I think that's what little
children do at the age of two and three
they're showing their independence I
think that's what teenagers are all
about and I had a very natural instinct
to try I don't know where I got the idea
that we should be consistent but I ended
up with I had that very early on that in
order for something to be presenting you
ought to be consistent in order to be
credible and and then when I got an
economic cite some of the things were
very natural and I think they're natural
for most people because people do want
peace and prosperity you don't have to
read that in book but it was in the 60s
when I came across some economist who
actually wrote great books great
intellectuals like Mises and Rothbard
and Hayek and these people I know these
guys are smart and they agree with me so
I would say yes this is it so that's
what got me really excited but then it
was the coming together and most people
see that I got involved in politics
because of the financing or war the
monetary system and the gold and all
this in the 70s and it is true that was
the particular issue but it was it was
the overall issue of individual liberty
which is connected to free market
economies and some money and a sensible
foreign policy which the founders
advised so it comes together and I think
the nicest compliment I get when I'm on
the road is I don't know why more people
don't agree with you because it's common
sense
so I like that compliment because and I
think that's why a lot of people agree
with it but they just don't get to hear
it
I mean politicians you know if they have
to contradict what they think their
district might went one even if it's
common sense no they have to play to the
audience and and and most aren't willing
to do this they they say all I have to
do this I work for the constituents and
they want more money for this project so
I have to go along or I'll get kicked
out and what are your best-selling books
in the Fed
from 2009 you right the Federal Reserve
should be abolished because it is
immoral unconstitutional impractical
promotes bad economics and undermines
Liberty its destructive nature makes it
a tool of tyrannical government I agree
with that that sounds like a good
statement now I actually strongly
believe that it is a tool of tyrants
because if you have control of the
printing presses you can control foreign
policy everything else in the finances
and you benefit now we talked a little
while ago about the basic principle if
you cave in a little bit you open up the
door for more and more well a lot of
people are very good-hearted and on both
sides of the aisle I think almost all of
them are good heart and they want to
help people who are having problem but
they don't realize that the most
humanitarian thing that they could do
for people for their prosperity is to
give them their freedom and but excuse
me in the fact that the Fed is involved
is you know the as they prompt make
these promises and the government wants
to do this then the Fed has so much
control but this principle of welfare
unfortunately backfires right now who
suffers the most a shrinking middle
class in the poor and then they've been
going downhill on their wealth since the
early 1970s now who got the bailouts in
7 & 8 you know foreign governments
foreign central banks international
corporations all the big companies and
who got stranded it was the poor people
who were talked into buying a house
which they probably shouldn't have
bought because the price was way too
high and they lost their job and they
lost their house so welfarism really
protects the wealthy the fan is
connected to this you can see if you run
up a debt and you have a military
industrial complex building weapons we
don't need bombers you know planes that
maybe you should be used 75 years ago
but we build them anyway
we build them in all 50 states and it's
just Cisco's it goes on and on they keep
making the money and then they fortify
this and they back it up I seen that's
what I learned in college my economic
teacher said deficits don't matter
spending money is good the reason you
have recessions people quit spending
their money it's not because they lost
their job or worried about the future
they just quit spending and if they if
they'd only spend they should borrow the
money and spend even if they're out of
money exactly what government does so
they this whole system is backed up
intellectually so this is an
intellectual fight and it's not a
political fight the politics is
secondary to what I'm talking about we
have to change people's minds they have
to have a different understanding they
have to study Austrian economics they
have to really say you see write about
this on the Federal Reserve and paper
money versus gold money and that's the
best thing that could happen this is not
so much to take all this for granted but
to say hey I better study this and find
out maybe maybe there is a strong point
maybe this common sense from Liberty
defined you quote HL Mencken a tale
Megan said the urge to save humanity is
almost always a false front for the urge
to rule then you go on and write but it
also requires the people's complacency
to buy into the free lunch argument not
everyone wants their freedom and accepts
responsibility for their own well-being
the problem is there are always
individuals who want to control others
and a significant number of people who
believe they will benefit forever from
the gravy train this allows the erosion
of Liberty to program yeah there's no
doubt about that
and yet that whole thing that he's
talking about there is supported by
intellectual leadership you know what
was taught in the colleges and you know
the our government what they teach and
the media and the professor's and they
they all teach these things but if the
intellectual leaders all of a sudden
explained the fallacies the fallacies of
the system we have and then the number
of people the large number of people
will ship intellectual leadership and
education is key to it that you
you don't have to get the majority of
the people to endorse one you know the
government or the government doesn't
exist but a joint of people probably you
know had to endorse communism when it
happened always thinking what man can
said they think they're going to get
something from it and there's always
somebody out there that why wouldn't
love sour and as I said before that's
the fight in Washington right now is the
fight over power not over ideology of
free markets and the foreign policy
because they endorse i its power and
some people gravitate to to Washington
politics because it's in it's in it's in
bread that they want to dictate to
others the one problem with the true
libertarian is they don't have this
burning desire to take over and run the
country you know that's not what we want
to do so they don't want to put out the
effort and I think that the effort if
you only had one effort it has to be in
changing people's minds and changing
their heart to understand you know if
they if their goal is to have a
humanitarian society and the society
that's more productive and more
prosperous then they have to they have
to study you know the economics of it
all and why Liberty is so important and
that I think and that'll give us the
answers that we need
Edward Perkins asks you via Twitter why
do we have an FBI CIA and NSA a pentagon
keep an eye on the people so they don't
try to undermine the government that's
to protect the government some of that I
mean I certainly have been strongly on
record about the CIA and the NSA and all
this but you know in a true Republic you
would not have that I mean we're if you
read the original Constitution where
does it say that okay and we're going to
have a department it's going to
establish a secret organization and you
can't on it you don't know what the
budget is and they're to go in and
undermine the governments of the world
and work with the military in order to
overthrow governments now I see it's not
there so this kind of thing if it's
necessary if you need somebody to
investigate accident
and crimes it can be done locally it
certainly was should have never been
done by the federal government there was
never to be a federal police force and
believe me we have about 120,000 federal
bureaucrats carrying guns you know to
enforce all these rules and regulations
and and the worst of situation gets the
more authoritarian to get it now you put
all these groups together Department of
Homeland Security they're going to make
us secure well that is not even the
purpose of government that purpose of
government is to make sure that we live
in a free society but the Department of
Homeland Security oh it's for security
we're going to make you economically
secure and we're going to make you
physically secure and for those and
there was a mission by some that that's
what they even had to use 911 for ah
this gives us an opportunity actually to
pass things like the Patriot Act because
that kind of stuff had been sitting
around so this was an opportunity for
the authoritarians who just and they
some just want to be authoritarian but
others and I've had members of Congress
tell me to say it to my face I said why
are you doing this you're just taking
over this you know a problem for the
people he says the people too stupid and
that's that's what some of them think
and that's what gives them this moral
authority that they know what's wrong
does that mean I think that if we
unleash freedom on all the people
everything is going to be fine
heavens no there's still going to be a
lot of problem but just think if you and
I have our freedoms and we do something
wrong or we don't cry
we only might injure ourselves or local
but if we're in the government and we're
running the NSA or the CIA and they're
doing all these bad things it affects
everybody when they have bad policy so
you don't want people making mistakes
what if you get people in Washington
that think they know how to do central
economic planning and that's what the
Federal Reserve is all about plan the
economy and we can make booms and we can
always make the booms and we never
caused the bus and they they'll do this
and of course it always fails so you
don't want people
in empower to be able to have this
control over the people let's take some
calls bills calling in from Boyer town
Pennsylvania go ahead bill you're on
with Ron Paul hi Ron it's a really
privilege to be speaking with you right
now I went to an earlier mass just so I
could get here and watch your program
the question that I have is what do you
what do we do here
you know I'm not an uneducated guy you
know I agree dennis kucinich in you a
lot of times we're the only guys that
seem to make any sense
and I've been following you since early
in your career I'm sitting here outside
of Reading Pennsylvania and I have
$10,000 worth of property tax bills that
in front of me that are due for my house
and a couple rentals I pay sixteen
thousand dollars in property tax a year
and you know my son just joined the
Pennsylvania National Guard I'm afraid
he's going to get sent over to the
Ukraine you know I know if your son runs
I'm going to get behind him and back him
but my question to you is what do we do
I mean they're all these problems I know
the Fed I buy gold I keep my money in
cash but what do we do - I thank you
very much let's get a response well
that's probably one of the most common
questions I have a lot of the college
kids will ask me about this and I don't
I don't have the answer because
everybody has to do something and every
and it won't be the same for everybody
else and since I've been more active
publicly in these last several years and
the presidential campaign so many have
come back to me and they so you told me
to do something and they start their own
organizations they do their own study
and they get their own jobs and someone
run for office somebody else other
candidate I said that politics is
secondary to to the education but having
good people in Washington they can
participate this and at least they hold
up their hands and say whoa wait what
you're doing is wrong
there's there's two parts of your
question one is your immediate problem
you know of this heavy tax burden and
and that's not going to go away
overnight but long-term is to shift
toward a freer society which isn't going
to happen overnight but the mess we got
into didn't happen you know overnight
either in fact the fed was started in
1913 and it just gradually got worse
every year it got worse and then brought
us to this catastrophe that we're
involved in now so what we need to do
and what is happening is those seeds are
being planted now the true intellectual
movement in this country is toward
understanding individual liberty a
different type of foreign policy a
different role for the government that
these wars are totally unnecessary so
first thing is educate oneself and I'm
sure the gentleman is well educated to
understand is it just seem like you know
I had these instincts but it took me a
long time in the 50s and the 60s to find
the right people to study and read and
understand Austrian economics but today
this information is so readily available
to us you know with the with the
internet that people can find this
information and that is what's happening
that's where the revolution is and
believe me I'm talking to a lot of young
people and a lot of them are very
interested and it's very slow though
that's the tough part the frustration
but just the whole fact that the Fed is
a debatable item right now and
non-interventionism overseas is a
debatable item that wasn't true even six
years ago and everybody knows about this
so there's been various organizations
that join up or make your own become
more informed if you're well-informed
people will come to you and ask you
opinion the one thing that can't be done
even if you have the absolutely correct
issues and the correct answers for this
you cannot push it on people because
they will rebel against it it is only
when they will come and finally sit down
and Congress there's been a few
occasions that I was just delighted with
that I'd be voting by myself
with two or three other people and
somebody would come to head and sit down
another member and honestly ask me why
are you doing this and explain it to
them and finally come around to my
position just by sitting and talking so
there's a lot of room changing people's
minds and changing people's hearts and
realizing it is in the best interest of
everybody to move in the direction of
more liberty and not less that doesn't
answer the question wholeheartedly but
it tell you what it's going to be a long
answer but we're at the beginning stages
and we're going in the right direction
well Ron Paul bill also mentioned that
his son joined the National Pennsylvania
National Guard he was fearful that he
was going to be sent to the Ukraine
here's what you write in 2008 from
pillars of prosperity our willingness
over the past 100 years to resort to
weapons to impose our will on others has
generally caused resentment of America
rather than respect there's there's no
doubt about that more so than ever and
the other important thing there is the
recruiting tool and it's the incitement
of people who not just resent us by hate
us and want to do us harm and look at
the harm that's been done to us half of
the harms been done overseas but as a
consequence of this the other has been
done by ourselves you know here at home
by violation of our own civil liberties
and spending too much money but no look
at the results of Iraq and Afghanistan
horrible and all the deaths and if this
just makes no sense whatsoever we have
more enemies right now they're just
waiting us for us to stumble we're
starting to stumble already there's an
attack it will be building on our dollar
other countries you know this
willy-nilly use of sanctions when they
have no evidence whatsoever of anything
and right now this absolutely
unnecessary aggravation of Russia makes
no sense whatsoever to do this they're
just looking for more trouble and they
they're going to when you put on
sanctions the people who put the homes
of sanctions have consequences to
- and Europeans will have consequences
on the current thing but just think of
home how many countries we've had
sanctions on and they've been not worth
much Cuba however they'd been on since
the 50s and now we've had we've had
sanctions on Iran for all these years
and it continues so I think people
resent it and they as we get weaker
militarily and financially there's going
to be a lot of piling on and I think
that we will be forced the gentleman
asked about what can we do actually I'm
pessimistic on the very short run I
think things are going to get much worse
we can't you know get enough people to
convert people in Washington all of a
sudden shift gears and do the right
thing but this thing is going to come
apart and we're going to have to make a
decision on what we want on economics on
civil liberties what kind of a foreign
policy want and that's when I think we
can find the right answers and do a much
better job so if you were sitting in the
White House right now and Russia is
involved in Ukraine is there a u.s. role
no I mean we are was it was it and it
was it a necessary for Russia to get
involved when we went into Haiti
did we think what the Russians has come
over you shouldn't be in Haiti and you
should be in all these different
countries or in Central America
we're in 140 countries already but the
that doesn't fully answer the question
because I'm a non-interventionist so I
say stay out of it and if unless it's a
threat to our national security has
nothing to do with our national security
going into Afghanistan and Iraq made it
more of a threat to our national
security you know because of all the
conditions that they create and the
results are so disastrous but we should
have stayed out of Ukraine a lot sooner
because we were in combination with the
Europeans to overthrow an elected
government
avianna Kovich so we were the one that
participated in the coup threw him out
and now we're bloom in Russia for
everything so and Russia happens to
have you know an argument is a little
bit stronger than ours you know
Ukraine and especially Crimea was part
of Russia for most of a thousand years
so people should back off a little bit
the perfect solution would be to get
Russia to move out United States to move
on with the Ukrainian solve the problem
but under these circumstances the only
thing that I might have you know more of
a moral authority or input is I can talk
about our own government and that is
that we shouldn't do these things
because they're not good for us and
they're wrong
but for us to you know go in looking for
fights continuously because the war
drums are beating and I think it's very
dangerous
they don't think there'll be a major war
i matter like i don't think there will
be a ground war either but they said and
obama said no boots on the ground well
we have boots on the ground we have
special forces of they're in the CIA
agents over there we have plenty of
boots on the ground we're sending a
military equipment we're begging for
more money to be on one side and that is
so unnecessary and so harmful if the
europeans thinks it's a big deal of what
the Russians are doing then leather your
pants deal with this I mean why why
should we put the burden on the poor
people of this country because the rich
don't suffer the poor suffer and because
that's the way the system works that's
the way the economy work that's why the
poor get poorer the middle class is
shrinking and we can't afford anymore
I've argued or made the point now I'm
not going to win this argument and all
of a sudden yeah Ron Paul is right let's
bring the troops home but they're coming
home they're coming home because we
won't be able to afford them and I think
it would be a blessing in disguise that
we just can't afford these wars because
we can't afford more of the tragedies
that we are causing for our veterans and
I come home and and they have so many so
many physical problems and mental
problems in the VA incapable of taking
care of them and trillions of dollars of
obligation so I would say no weaken we
can't afford that
any longer and a change foreign policy
we'd have been following a
non-interventionist constitutional
foreign policy since the end of World
War two can you imagine how many lives
would have been sold honey lies did we
destroy in how many of our American Pia
American soldiers died in Korea and
Vietnam and these new Wars and all these
tragedies
they would have been avoided and we
would not have been great we would have
been less threatened under those
conditions people say well no we did ask
to prevent the invasion baloney they
weren't about to invade us they're more
likely to invade us now because of our
pushing ourselves around and becoming
the authoritarians and now if a
principle in our government established
by Bush that we should have pre-emptive
war well that's aggression pre-emptive
war means well they might attack us
someday someday the Iranian might get a
nuclear weapon so they're they're our
enemy so we have the moral authority to
start the war that is not part of
America and shouldn't be and we
shouldn't have part of America now where
our presidents actually think they can
assassinate American citizens
so we've been a long way off from our
Constitution but believe it I'm still
optimistic the young people will realize
this and they would like to see us move
in a better direction well even though
you're only four years old 1939 do you
think you would have been in America
first er before World War two absolutely
you know Robert Robert Taft was in that
group and he was then 1945 to he rubber
town mr. Republican we have a statute
for him and he said don't even join NATO
they're going to get us involved who's
pushing us who gave us the authority to
go into Libya and Syria and now Ukraine
NATO
he says that will undermine our national
faith so people you know a presence get
up there and argue Republican and
Democrat we all need a declaration where
we get our authority from the United
Nations and NATO so they were around
back
and there are more of them now believe
me robert toth would fit in quite well
right now and we'd be a lot better off
if we had more people convinced there so
someday I'd like to see see a point
where the young people just say hey I
don't need this war I'm not going and I
of course I got drafted I went I was in
for five years but there would be a day
coming I'd hate to see one of my excuse
me one of my kids if there's a hot war
in Ukraine or to be sent over there or
to be sent to a war with the Iranians or
were with in Afghanistan I mean Iraq
such a waste
and I just don't I just don't think that
people want that anymore I think they
get talked into it there's war
propaganda the television stations and
all the politicians you have to do it
propaganda now against Russia they have
been very successful because when this
thing first started out there is hardly
anybody thought we should confront
Russia but now that they come up with
this wild story about Russia shooting
down an airliner
everybody hates Russia now and Putin
this Hitler
it's absolutely absurd at the same time
nobody knows exactly who shot the
airliner down right now there's evidence
popping up that it could have come from
Western Ukraine and the whole thing is
is I don't know nobody knows for sure
and that's a real good argument for why
don't we stay out of that mess because
nobody has threatened America and nobody
has threatened our national security
drew Mill Valley California good
afternoon or good morning you're on the
Ron Paul of Thai there are you very good
okay so dr. Paul um I've been a big fan
of yours for a while now 26 years ago in
1988 the deficit was a hundred and fifty
five billion I believe and now we're
looking at trillions of dollars in debt
we know we're in do you think that we
need to change our economic structure so
I think I know the answer this is
intended if so how do we go about it
what would be the plan well yes we need
a different one and if we want to talk
real practical politics and economics
the plan can't be depending on changing
the face of Congress who all of a sudden
will balance the budget and pay down the
debt it's recognizing the truth of the
situation the truth of the situation is
17 trillion dollar debt at this size
will never be paid it will be liquidated
governments think they can liquidate it
by paying it off with bad money that is
debase the currency which they're
working real hard at and the prices
aren't going up quite as fast as the Fed
would like because is when you debase
the purchasing power of the dollar the
real debt goes down so the the debt will
be liquidated and when it's liquidated
if it will be totally liquidated if you
have runaway inflation which is a
possibility then you have to restore
soundness to the economy by having free
markets and a sound currency get rid of
them get rid of the Fed but you have to
change the attitude of the people the
people still can't say yes but I'm on
food stamps I'm going to dive I don't
get food stamps and then you have the
military-industrial complex as what
about our food stamps because we're
really the important people we make
weapons to protect our our country of
course the weapons aren't necessary so
everybody's going to argue as long as
you have that it's going to be very very
bad so we have to at the time the
bankruptcy occurs and the liquidation of
current debt occurs then we have to have
people or firmly convinced that the
economic system and the foreign policy
system that we have today is completely
wrong there has to be a respect for our
privacy once again in civil liberties
and it's all baked back to getting the
majority of the people to go along with
our intellectual leaders to say that
individual liberty can solve these
problems the Constitution is a good
document to start with and the founders
were on the right track but we
have to admit that we're nowhere close
to that and then when it is recognized
that we have gone the wrong way for a
long time then we have a chance you know
to pick up the pieces and restore
liberty and prosperity to this country
now if you can't get through on the
phone lines and want to make a comment
you can go to Facebook Twitter or you
can email as well and we'll flesh those
addresses up as we go but here's a
comment from our Facebook page Ron Paul
this is from Z Tov Marcia nur and dr.
Paul what advice can you give to a
German political science student what
studies do you like to see in the future
at my university we don't get educated
in the ideas of liberty at all well I
can't speak for German universities they
may have a lot more freedom of choice
and we have here I would say don't
depend on the University and go to the
internet and look up Austrian economics
and look up the the writings of Mises
and Hayek and and Rothbard and others
and and find out what that's all about
because it is that understanding by as
many people as possible that will make
the difference now there may be some
good professors that understand free
markets and sound money in the European
schools
matter of fact I'm always encouraged I
get a lot of invitations to Europe and
South America I'll be going down to a
group Mises Institute group down in
Brazil and I've been into Chile so these
ideas are spreading and this is of
course very very good but it's going to
be not an easy fight to say the least
but for somebody in Germany fortunately
we have the Internet I mean here we are
talking to somebody from Germany and and
I think that is great I think that this
this whole idea is spreading easily now
that we have this available technique
through the internet Ron Paul from your
book the school revolution colleges want
to get students enrolled as freshmen
because this is where they make most of
their money it costs relatively little
to teach freshmen or sophomores yet the
tuition payment is the same
for upper-division years the upper
division is where the student majors in
the particular subject this is where he
gets taught by PhD holding professors
rather than graduate assistants the
payoff in education for the student is
in the upper division therefore colleges
do their best to persuade parents and
students that it is necessary to spend
the first two years on campus it is not
necessary you write either economically
or academically but it is not in the
self-interest of colleges that families
understand no and I think there's
something flawed in this in the system
if you do very well and there's some
still good universities in science and
engineering but there's way too much a
college degree now if I had to start
over today and still wanted to do I did
I'd still be sort of forced into the
conventional system because I wanted to
be an MD so you go through the ritual of
the college and and and and the medical
school but there are so many others I'm
seeing and everybody hears the stories
and some of these people who have a few
bucks in made a lot of money probably
never even went to college and but but
they have to get their edges that
doesn't mean they don't get educated
it's just that the their say it is a
boondoggle an education system not only
at the college level but at all levels
because government is so involved
there's no authority in the Constitution
but the federal government to be
involved in education and then there's
the printing press money which means
that there's a lot of extra money and
then there's the laws passed and money
goes into certain directions on based on
that so because we're involved in in
education what it does more people get
degrees but the degree gets cheapened
but it costs more money and so a lot of
people are coming out with degrees and a
lot of debt and no jobs so people have
to ask themselves you know maybe there
is something wrong with our educational
system
you know if the degree isn't meaning
much anymore so III think that it's not
necessary for everybody
60,000 a year for top university anymore
I didn't even realize I guess I better
catch up there 16,000 done and and
everybody feels everybody's been
brainwashed you God has sacrificed for
your kid you know to go to school well
you know it what a change this in my
lifetime you know I could get a few jobs
on campus and pay for my tuition you
know in the 50s and there are five of us
in our family we're real close so we
were expected to take care of summer
working John's on the campus we could
pay our own tuition but now those prices
are inflated and it is a consequence
they're teaching you bad economics and
you're getting punished by bad economics
but we never change anything
60,000 I guess I'll have to work I guess
I'll have to borrow the money and
participate in it government has 17
trillion dollars of debt well I can go
and educate my child for three or four
hundred thousand dollars but I'll be
doing them a great service but then they
might not get a job so we have to at
least stop and ask some questions about
this but that type of thing is a
consequence of bad economic planning by
a government that should not be in the
business of economic planning and they
should be subsidizing it through
printing press money which means there's
a lot of money out there housing bubbles
can be explained in the same manner Gus
Naples Florida thanks for holding your
own with Ron Paul
I thought the Politan honor to speak
with you I had two questions do you
think Janet Yellen has more power and
influence in the president united state
and the second question is what should
the guidelines be portrayed agreement
thank you okay yes I think the I think
the Chairman the Federal Reserve Board
has more clout and more power then then
a president on economic matters I mean
the president has tremendous power on
the military matters so on economic
matters the the chairman of the Fed is
very very powerful and it's done in
secrecy and that's that's really the big
big problem there that's why I argue
that we should have have an audit now
you asked about what should be the trunk
traditions on on trade agreements well
the Constitution said to Congress should
be in charge of trade agreements
and they should be and it was assumed to
be bilateral so if the Congress wanted
to act on a free trade zone between the
United States and Canada Congress could
pass a law and set the trade standards
and of course they were very the
founders were very strong free traders
they didn't want a lot of barriers and
they did not want a lot of of problems
even though it was legal to put on on on
tariffs but when you have these trade
agreements multilateral trade agreements
and the worst of course is the WTO
they're nothing more than groups of big
companies get together and get
permission to put on sanctions when they
feel like their competition is is
harming them so they they spend as much
time putting putting on tariffs to
prevent some imports in order to protect
what they are selling as they do you
know trying to reduce tariffs so we
don't need that we should argue the case
for free trade but it should be the
Congress I always voted against them
basically because I did not believe the
president should have this power and
authority to write these trade
agreements and that was another issue
that Dennis and I agreed on on economics
because you know they would violate some
of his concepts about labor law so it's
a but giving the power to the president
was is is the problem and it should be
in the Congress and it wouldn't create a
perfect world but it'd be a lot better
than the world we have today where
special interests controlled trade
agreements now that you're both out of
Congress do you still stay in touch with
congressman Kucinich we do and he's on
my board on one of my Institute's the
Institute for peace and prosperity which
is a Foreign Policy Board so he's an
advisor there from your book in the Fed
2009 you write the Supreme Court has
never been a friend of sound money and
has rarely been a protector of the
Constitution the only unique power that
the Fed possesses is the power to
inspire and support the creation of new
money out of nothing who needs that
thanks like it governments like it high
flying financiers like it but the people
do not benefit just the reverse well
that unfortunately is the conclusion of
it but some people believe they're going
to benefit by it we talked a little bit
about the housing bubble when little
interest rates were there and it looked
like it would last forever endorse that
but it backfired on them so no it only
benefits the special interests and they
should not have this power and when it
goes into courses as far back as well
through our history they've never ruled
in favor of some money especially during
the Civil War period when they cried the
greenbacks and different things like
this so and they're not likely to ever
come around to supporting that position
either today so there has to be a new
group of Supreme Court justices in and a
few new ideas
you're watching book TV on c-span 248
hours of nonfiction books and authors
every weekend currently Ron Paul is our
guest dr. congressman presidential
candidate author of several books almost
a dozen Anthony Valencia California
please go ahead with your question or
coming hello dr. Paul it's an honor to
speak to you hello hi I just have one
question and the question is your view
on what's going on today and in Gaza and
Israel the conflict the genocide it
seems like it's getting a lot more news
coverage not so much with our media but
with other media outlets especially
Democracy Now and Amy Goodman so I just
wanted to get your view I know how you
feel I followed your fears and I'll get
off the line and give your view thank
you well my answer for that is the
answer that I use for all entanglements
around the world we shouldn't be
involved we should be non intervenors we
shouldn't we should pick sides we don't
send foreign aid to anybody foreign aid
is nothing more than taking money from
poor people in this country giving it to
rich governments or giving it to the
military-industrial
Plax indirectly so so we shouldn't
shouldn't be involved you know Netanyahu
said something to our president this
week he rather aggressively told our
president don't ever second-guess me
again on what I should do and you know
what I agree with Netanyahu on that we
shouldn't second-guess him he he
shouldn't have to give up his
sovereignty he shouldn't have to be told
what to do and they should be able to do
what they want but they shouldn't get
any money from us you know what's given
Israel hundred billion dollars and then
the president of Israel is annoyed
because the president thinks he has a
little say in the matter I don't think
we should have any say in the matter I
think Israel should defend themselves
the way they see put I think the
Palestinians should do what they want to
do and the help they can get but I think
we've been butting in there for way too
long it's cost us a lot of money how
many times that we had you know been the
host of a peace process the other day
that got angry at Kerry for trying to
participate in it he didn't say the
right things they practically ran him
out of town so that's not our role our
role is to provide a national defense
and security for our people and provide
for liberty the one thing is though if
you're a Palestinian American and you
want to say well I don't like the way
the Palestinians are being treated you
can go to Palestine under a free society
probably can't do it under the laws
today go over there and help them send
them money same way with Israel your
support of this rule and you want to go
fight I know Americans go and get in the
Israeli army
there should be no prohibitions of that
but there should be no compulsions to
send our kids over there or send our
children's and marrying people's money
over there so I would say that Netanyahu
is absolutely right we shouldn't
second-guess him but he should be
cautious not to second-guess us because
maybe we'll run out of money or maybe
we'll get tired of sending money because
right this week we sent a bonus of 225
million dollars to help him fight the
war against the Palestinians and that's
not the road to peace for anybody I
think that is that makes us a moral
participant in what's going on over
there just as we are a moral
participant in aiding the Western
Ukrainians against the eastern Ukrainian
so there is a moral responsibility and
for us to lecture others and say well
it's all one side fault or the others it
it's just wrong I mean how many times
have you heard on TV in the last several
weeks that Israel has a right to defend
herself absolutely she has a right to
defend ourselves but never once you hear
the Palestinians have a right to defend
themselves
no you never hear that so we we should
be more balanced on that and I think
that the best way to do that is for us
to not send any money or any troops or
any weapons into any region any place in
the world from live Liberty defined Ron
Paul writes we should not go to war
without a declaration we should not go
to war when it's an aggressive war we
should take an honest look at all the
ways in which US policy incites
desperate people to take extreme
measures as retaliation for u.s.
sponsored political violence
Dennis West Palm Beach Florida you're on
the air
dr. Paul you're a champion of Liberty
and the First Amendment to our
Constitution guarantees the freedom to
exercise our religion we pay all of our
adult lives taxes to the government for
education so my question is should the
parents of America receive their taxes
back in the form of a voucher to send
their children to the school of their
choice including a religiously
affiliated one or should the government
continue to have the power to force our
children to go to atheistic schools no
they shouldn't happen what do you think
Dennis I think that I think that the
parents should have the right to
exercise the religion and to the US
Supreme Court in the zelma V Harris
Simmons case in 2002 dr. Paul said that
school vouchers did not violate the US
Constitution as long as the voucher was
given to the parent to use where they
saw fit but it would be a violation of
the First Amendment if the voucher given
directly to a religiously affiliated
school well I don't I don't want the
federal government involved in educating
so I don't want them collecting money
for
one group and giving it out to somebody
else I see this more as an intervention
in education by the government rather
than a First Amendment issue I think
that people should go to any schools
they want and it should be local if
you're going to have government under
the Constitution the states can do what
they want but it was much better you
know when it was only your local
community just the the town that you
lived in where the highest authority was
the school board and that would that
would you know be the authority but I
don't I do another reason I'm not too
gung-ho over vouchers is it sounds like
it's helpful I've supported bills that
we give you a tax credit where you just
wrote it off and if you if you spent so
much money sending your kid to a school
you can deduct that off your taxes but
the voucher when the government send you
your voucher and say well this is what
you can do then they can send the
regulations and tell you where you can
use your voucher and say well okay what
school and then you have to get into
this thing that we have to monitor the
school and what you're teaching and
these different things so I would much
rather see just the use of tax credits
but not to bounce your next call for Ron
Paul comes from Michael White Plains
Maryland Michael you're on book TV yes
thank you dr. Paul for waking me up from
the economy of arguments played out by
our current and bipartisan systems than
a big game changer for me regarding your
remarks on a self-governing America what
is your position on the second Clause of
article 5 heavily contributed to by
George Mason that allows the state
legislatures to bypass Congress to
create a constitutional amendment by the
way I thought all Terminix
thank you well it's are there in the
Constitution and the states can call for
a constitutional convention I I mean I
think it's fine I'm not that optimistic
I'm not in charge of an organization
that's pushing for this because I think
you have to change people's minds about
what they're going to do because if you
have a constitutional convention right
now you
know what actually what we've all they
might make things worse
depends on what issues that they're
they're bringing out now the gentlemen
say that it was to bring it up for term
limits he said and that he added that he
was in support of term term limits well
you know never maybe to say there's a
constitutional amendment to to limit
terms I I've always voted for term
limits and I introduced legislation that
way but I don't have much confidence in
it because I've seen some people leave
when they voluntarily had term limits
and the people who got really got
elected in that position they were much
worse you know there wasn't an
improvement at all so I don't think that
that is the answer in itself but it
might help a little bit but if you if
you don't change people's understanding
of economics if we don't spread the
message of how free markets work and the
understanding of the Fed and why don't
we ought to bring our troops home
limiting limiting those terms aren't
aren't going to help very much kate is
calling in from Montclair New Jersey
hi Kate hi I have a question regarding
foreign policy in areas such as
therefore and South Sudan we would be an
appropriate approach their diplomatic
Lee or other means to help people who
are undergoing such horrible atrocities
okay what do you think would be an
appropriate approach well um I really
confused about it because sections such
as that add and we'd soon to think for
the people to take on themselves and I
do feel that I need assistance pretty
much you know emergency assistance ID
I'm very dismayed by the type of
violence that goes on there and all over
the world but really for me especially
just going on for so long and so many
people has been terribly affected thank
you ma'am Peter I wasn't quite able to
follow that could you yet she asked
about what do you think the
the us approach should be for
humanitarian assistance somebody comes
to add our fur or a South Sudan
something like that I think that's a
reasonable question and of course my
answer is the same if you want if you
have some money you want to help them
send the money but it's not proper to do
this to take money from people in this
country because you think you're going
to help somebody over there but the the
problem is so often is when we do that
we send money it is up in two warring
factions and it doesn't end up helping
the poor people a lot of times people
will vote for this where they wouldn't
vote for any of the militarism and I can
understand that because I certainly
would have more sympathy to helping
people like that but they will do that
but first taking the money is wrong and
second it doesn't end up doing a very
good job so I don't think I don't think
that we should we should do that now the
only thing that I have and in between
percent process would be that if I could
let's say there are there is some of
this problems in a country in Africa and
they really really need some help and we
think that we can help if we could cut
ten billion dollars out of some nonsense
in building embassy someplace in Iraq
and send part of that to feeding people
and we save eight billion dollars doing
it you know I would think that would be
an improvement you know we saved some
money we cut the spending and we sent
some money for food and send stead of
sending money for weapon I would
probably go along with that but it's not
weird but but if it would come up and
say do you have sympathy for these
people yes we do but will you vote for
the money to take from the American
people is it authorized under
Constitution it isn't so I wouldn't vote
for that Ron Paul from our Facebook page
another question for you this is william
considering the interest on the debt is
unconstitutional
could we just eliminate this interest at
least the part created by the federal
reserve it's unquestionably
unconstitutional well the federal
reserve is unconstitutional and if
you're doing
with the death in the park the Fed owns
you can just write it off you don't have
to pay
why pay them the money so you could
write that part off but I think the the
issue of our government borrowing money
we unfortunately started very early to
do that because we started off with a
debt and if foreigners loaned us money
or individuals loaned us money and the
contract was that they would get paid a
certain amount of interest I think if we
were working our way out of it we should
take care of that but I don't think that
will ever happen and we're not going to
liquidate the debt with the Fed I think
the whole system might get liquidated
and everything gets written off because
the dollar
you know collapses but that's a
different story but it you can you can
just forget about the Fed if you get rid
of the thin radical Taoists tweets into
you what would happen if the dollar
collapses would governments be able to
survive oh yeah unfortunately government
survival survivability it's pretty good
so they survive the question is what
will that government be like but I
suspect what will happen is things will
get more out of control and you're going
to see rampant inflation and interest
rates rising our economy doing very
badly and then they will realize they
have to have reform to you know pick up
the pieces so if they don't do that then
if you had total runaway inflation the
dollar collapses that's bad news that's
bad news economically and then you have
a Zimbabwe example but you know Zimbabwe
had runaway inflation then we don't even
hear him in the news anymore they had a
new currency and they you know
reestablish their system and so they're
back functioning again so so it can it
can be done we were close to that
happening in our country in in 1979 and
Volcker when he came in he said we have
to save the dollar so he took interest
rates up to 21 percent but today's
circumstances are different they're
there at zero percent but the federal
government unfortunately is going to you
know remain pretty resilient
and pretty strong but hopefully when the
revamping in the reforms that we will
know how to reduce the size and scope of
government the ROM back report tweets in
the 99% has been losing ground to the 1%
ever since the u.s. lost its last link
to gold in 1971 when Nixon abandoned
Bretton Woods no doubt about it the rich
have done very well since 1971 actually
real wealth is down real wages are down
and middle-class is smaller and it's a
it is a truism that the gold standard is
a benefit to the average person to call
the man labor because the wages you know
stay up
they don't collapse real wages are going
down now because the purchasing power is
going down faster than the government
admits they say well we want the
purchasing power of our dollar to go
down at a rate of two two and a half
percent they think that is good so how
can anybody argue a moral case for
saying well if I give you a hundred
dollars and you pay me back next year
and you know it's going to be worth 98
98 dollars there's something wrong with
that and that that is the case that's
what they want they want to do it but
the breakdown of the Federal Reserve or
the Bretton Woods with a big item and it
is not help the poor people okay mark
pilling of Hollywood Florida email I
believe you to be the most
constitutional congressman in the
history of our lifetimes thank you for
your service I know at your age it
becomes difficult to run for president
again could I believe it gives Americans
an opportunity to be exposed to real
Liberty through your words and actions I
believe after eight years of the Obama
administration many liberals are waking
up to how similar both parties are and
there's a chance to unite Americans and
help them become polarized to their
nation instead of their party
I know Rand is working on this too would
you consider running for president in
2016
no how nice I'm not going to do that
I've learned anything is going well
mainly because I've done that and all
those years the debt kept getting worse
so I have to think well where's my
strategy now so when I mean officer out
of office I only have one goal and that
is campaigning for liberty so I can do
that outside and and I'm going to spend
a lot of time on education and that's
where I think my role is right now
you're 79 years old how do you feel I
feel pretty good and I as long as I get
out on my bike but today I came to be
with CC I'm gonna miss my bike ride
Wilburn is calling in from Southaven
Mississippi hi Wilbur hi I would just
like to say that I'm a true libertarian
and key party member because of mr. Paul
and President Reagan I want you to know
you're my hero I worry about the CIA
killing you are in if you get too close
to winning the White House also they
want to cancel our Second Amendment
because of more government control thank
you sir for all you do you know you
talks about the Second Amendment he'll
be surprised to know that I want gun
control but I want gun control those
120,000 government federal bureaucrats
who are federal policemen we need to
take their guns away from them but no
true security comes from individuals and
homeowners and people who have guns and
I kid but serious and it's true program
a lot of part of the country but in
Texas you don't have policemen guarding
those houses hey but most people know
there's a gun inside and security is is
quite reasonable but to depend on the
government for that and and to attack
the Second Amendment I think in a
dangerous direction to go in what about
his first point about the CIA did you
ever feel that you were threatening the
structure of the US government yeah uh
you know I was convinced they still saw
me as a very long shot but they didn't
understand something that ideas are more
powerful than political code so they
sort of said well we can't stop the
ideas and we're not going to try to do
that but politically
yeah they're capable of doing that I
mean I mean do you know how many people
in this countries are really questioning
the fact that the CIA might have been
involved in the Kennedy assassination a
lot and of course I don't know I don't
think anybody has the final answer that
but it's just that American people think
that they have been capable of doing
that so yes I don't I don't think we
should laugh at it
but I I'm on the same breath you know I
don't go around thinking that I'm
important enough for them to worry about
me you know and they didn't see me as a
political threat but the whole thing is
is ideas are more important than guns
and bureaucrats and presidents and all
that
it's a ideas have consequences and they
are very very powerful you know and it
was business said that you know if an
army comes to attack us we can always
stand up and oppose them Victor Hugo
made this comment but he says you know
when an idea comes you can't stop it you
know and that's what's happening the
ideas are out there and we have this
magic thing called the internet so
people from Germany call and write and
all around the world you know the the
ideas are spreading so and they're more
powerful than armies and I hope they
don't catch on the CIA may change their
tactics 38 years ago you were first
elected to Congress in 1976 but 40 years
ago about this time
President Nixon resigned from office do
you remember where you were during
Watergate what you were doing what you
thought about it you know because 71 it
was the breakdown of Bretton Woods and
that was when it dawned on me that the
Austrian economists at had been study
and were absolutely right because they
predicted it it would lead to this chaos
economic chaos that we're facing today
so in 1973 he resigned in 74 74 okay in
73
is when I went to my wife I said I'm
gonna run for Congress she said what do
you want to see dam for and I said well
I want to talk about this Federal
Reserve and all this and she said don't
do it dangerous she might get elected
and I guaranteed her that couldn't
possibly be the case and I bet you that
and so I signed up and nobody would want
to run into Watergate years so there
were no Republicans running or no
Republicans in Texas so I was a
candidate in 74 but when that was all
going on I was a political candidate in
my maya and of course nobody was
listening to me and nobody really cared
about my opinion but at the time I I
wasn't I wasn't like oh yeah if we get
rid of Nixon everything is going to be
okay I think it was overkill because I
thought the big problems were you know
in economic policy and the Federal
Reserve and the economy was terrible and
I figured these are just political stuff
that's been going on for a long time and
now it looks like some of the things he
did probably minor compared to what's
going on now with the IRS another thing
so that was a minor problem then but I
do remember that very clearly so I think
I was in my and probably never said it
out loud but I was sort of rooting that
he didn't get impeached and I thought it
was too disruptive but now I have a
little different opinion I think that
the more we changed the personnel the
better Ron Paul is our guest here on
book TV here are some of his books that
he has written freedom under siege the
US Constitution after 200 years came out
in 1987 the Ron Paul money book in 91 a
foreign policy of freedom peace Commerce
and honest friendship 2007 pillars of
prosperity o8 the revolution a manifesto
a best-seller also came out in oh wait
and the Fed another bestseller 2009
Liberty defined 50 essential issues that
affect our freedom 2011 and dr. Paul's
most recent book the school revolution a
new answer for our broken education
system in Congress 1976 77 1979 285 and
then again 1997 to 2013 presidential
Canada 1988 2008 and 2012
Carlos Cape Coral Florida thanks for
holding you are on with Ron Paul alright
the purple I see you as a burst of all
things outside the box it's one thing
for years ago the population of the
earth was about 700 million now it's
about 6.7 billion I don't see any
officials ever talking about this do you
think that it's an issue that we are
over populating a finite planet and
that's maybe because a lot of the
problems that we have you know back in
biblical times a couple of Hebrew guided
there are animals were grazing too much
and that's where you go to little F and
I go to the right but now there is no
left or right to go to can you address
your thoughts on the population
explosion that we're experiencing this
was 40 bigots thank you so much Carlos
before we get a dr. Paul's response
could you run those figures by us once
again just populate a width about them
under million on this a Bobby Darin song
for the 60 that you know that 700
million out there six point flows
billion and so you're saying there are
700 million people what 40 years ago 50
years ago about yeah yeah that's what
you know this semester he doesn't it
sounds a little long I know we have a de
principle he's right - first of all
concern about overpopulation I'll I
don't I don't worry about that I worry
about where they they get to live in a
free society you know the most advanced
the society gets you know the smaller
the families get and the more productive
it is the more you can take care of so
all the you know Malthus and others have
made these dire predictions that no is
it was unsustainable but that's been
going on for hundreds and hundreds of
years so to me it's pretty amazing how
technology adjust to these needs so
agriculture of these various things are
you know very very productive though it
is the political system that
surrounds the population that makes all
the difference in the world if you have
an authoritarian government if you have
bad economic policy you're just going to
have more people living in poverty and
we're certainly seeing what's happening
today with bad economic policies in
Central America and Mexico and also bad
policy here United States and and
everybody's worried about this that
wouldn't happen in a free society I have
a lot of confidence on how things would
work out and if if populations seem to
be growing too rapidly I think I think a
lot of the solutions would be natural
these are these individuals I think we
should have population control by force
that's you know something that China you
know goes through but not in a free
society I think more the freeter society
the lessons problems would be even
noticed Ron Paul this is something you
write about Liberty defined but this is
an email to you from Abie Turay hi I've
heard Ron Paul mention abortion and
various appearances on c-span over the
past few years
I remember hearing him say that in
certain hospitals in which he was doing
his training he was aware that abortions
were taking place and he said later that
when he had his own medical practice
women would have a very casual attitude
about abortion could he tell us any
information he has on this topic or any
stories which have remained in his mind
of course I don't think I guess we might
not have sent you the book I have
abortion on liberty that is another
Brooklyn I write a whole book on it
because I've had a unique opportunity to
think of it as an OB doctor somebody who
has you know religious beliefs and also
been in politics and had to deal with it
legally and I think she's referring to a
story that I quoted that before
abortions were legal I was observing an
operation in the operating room where I
was doing my residency and they were
doing a cesarean section and they lifted
out the fetus which weighed a couple
pounds and
and here I found out it was an abortion
they were doing so they took they took
the infant then and was born and put it
in a bucket and put it in the corner of
the room and the baby cried and
whimpered and breathed a little bit and
the amazing thing was everybody just
pretended they didn't hear it and there
was no effort to do anything it then a
day or two later I was walking down the
corridor and a woman had a baby
prematurely it was slightly bigger than
that baby
and they had ten doctors surrounding
that baby trying to save that baby's
life he got to thinking you know I I saw
medicine and delivering babies as
preservation of life and caring for life
and it was such a contradiction so
there's a lot of contradictions you know
in the end the abortion issue and it
really boils down to whether or not you
you think an unborn fetus has any rights
at all I've come to the conclusion that
they do because I know that if I did
something wrong as a doctor I could be
sued for injuring the baby if a baby
gets killed in an accident the person
that did to harm is it can be charged
with murder and one thing is amazing to
me about this abortion issue is we teach
us disrespect for life and we teach
young girls and our whole society that
babies aren't worth much and you can
throw them away if you don't think it's
necessary but this believe it or not
there are some young girls who get
pregnant they get in denial they don't
realize they're pregnant and they
deliver a baby and they're not quite did
not know and really what's going on so
they'll take the baby and they'll throw
it away I'll put it in a garbage bag and
throw it away when they get caught they
get they get charged with murder it's a
felony to do this and I think you know
this sort of has to be resolved one
minute sooner that have gone to the
abortionist because it would have been a
late abortion the doctor would have been
paid a lot of money to do this but the
next minute when the child is having
this baby interprets society saying well
it has no value all of a sudden is a big
issue so I have
a great deal of empathy for the problem
because I've seen all the all the
negative things that can happen just
about every political party has a
division there that even in Libertarian
Party there are a lot of right to life
liberty reans and a lot of right to
abortion people but overall I don't want
the federal government involved I don't
want money being spent one of the worst
things it's ever done by the
pro-abortion people is tax to people who
have this fervent belief against
abortion take money from them and send
it to clinics that do abortions you know
and that's that really is spitting in
somebody's face you know to do that
but even though I states have a right to
to regulate this I think once again it's
a reflection of society mentioned that
you know when that abortion was done at
my hospital where I was a resident and
it was illegal it was in the 60s
well the 60s were a wild decade Vietnam
war was going on the drug-crazed
abortion became popular and then the
Supreme Court rules it was okay so it
isn't because of Roe vs. Wade I don't
like what surveillant Roe versus way
reflects the culture and the morality of
the people so if we're going to solve a
problem like this you know probably at
the beginning of our country and for a
long period of time abortions weren't
done because people didn't believe in
them the culture was different and I
think that will eventually be the answer
there are some pro-life groups they
don't even deal in politics they don't
they don't even get involved they just
try to help the person who's in distress
over the pregnancy and I'm strongly in
favor of that I think it's a it's a
personal moral problem and the law is
sort of catches up to you know this
careless attitude which was established
in the 1960s and you're an obstetrician
right Vance Plainview Texas please go
ahead with your question or comment or
Ron Paul yes I'd be interested in his
opinion about the current health care
system from the viewpoint
that we are 5% of the world's population
but we spend 50% of all the my spent on
health care and we have a terrible
longevity allied record that's it now I
think our medical system is uh you know
in bad shape there's a lot of good
medicine still out there if you have to
go to the emergency room and have to
have an emergency care after an accident
it's pretty good but there's so many
distortions in medicine the pricing
structure is outrageous and paying for
the emergency room is just unbelievable
there's a physician in Oklahoma City
that I had interviewed on my channel
that has gone private doesn't take any
government no insurance anything and he
can accomplish a thirty thousand dollar
operation in a regular hospital for
three thousand dollars it's all the
bureaucracy trace it back to when the
government got involved and that's been
in early 1960s sixty four or five you
know with Medicaid I practiced medicine
for a short period of time before any
government was really involved and back
then everybody got charged the least and
there were Church Hospital still there
were Charity Hospital and nobody was on
the street with no medical care now we
have the government involved it's sort
of like when we talked about on
education money goes in prices go up
quality goes down and that's where we
are and I think that's about all we've
been talking about on the problems
coming with Obamacare we've given up our
belief and confidence that you know free
markets can deliver goods and services
much better than any government can so I
think the only saving grace on any of
these programs is always to protect our
right to opt out when if they say you
can't go to home schooling or a private
school anymore we're in big trouble if
you can't opt out of the medical system
and go private you're we're all in
trouble too and today it's getting
harder and harder to get out of the
medical system and it's pretty hard and
people are just beginning to feel what
kind of prices we're going to get from
this Obamacare and believe me there will
be
when the prices go up then there's
rationing it goes on doctors get less
happy it's it's going to it's going to
be a real mess and I think most
Americans right now are starting to feel
the pain so someone who's 79 do you
support Social Security Medicare do you
utilize those systems you know I I have
I take Social Security believing that
the government actually said this was a
you know a program which is which it
really isn't but no it's it's not it's
not a proper function of government but
there's a lot of contracts that
governments have in this imperfect world
to me it's sort of like saying well are
you going to send everything by FedEx
because we we don't want to use this
bureaucracy this monopoly of the federal
government but now the the Medicare and
Social Security when we you know we
talked about a climactic and that will
all end because the money won't be there
and costs will go up and standard living
is going down on people on fixed incomes
right now they're they're really
struggling you know because they can't
keep up and that's one of the reasons
why the CPI is always kept artificially
low is because then they don't have to
raise the cost you know the benefits the
Social Security beneficiary so they they
see their standard of living going down
so that's going to continue is going to
get much worse and they will eventually
have to be a revamping of that but it's
the the assumption is if you didn't have
it there wouldn't have been anything but
that's that's not the case it might have
been a lot better our city and Galveston
which was in my district their
government operations there that whole
county they never got into Social
Security and they're glad they're not
into it and they have a retirement fund
is better than Social Security so but
when you're forced into it's a it's a
different story you know and I think
that I think it won't be the same for
the generation right now going to going
into the workforce they're expected to
pay
a lot of money in there they're not
going to see it and it will have to
change they'll have to be some very big
changes in Social Security
Victor Rockledge Florida hi Victor hi hi
Ron Paul for waiting thank you for
waking me up and my friends and waking
up the country a little bit so my
question is if you were a voter in the
next election would you vote for a
libertarian candidate who has a policy
very similar to your own
you mean from another libertarian party
yeah someone with the tenets of freedom
something like Gary Johnson or would you
vote for Rand Paul who doesn't seem to
necessarily have same policies as you
victor will get an answer in two seconds
but who are you liking in 2016 um what I
typically do and when I do the last plan
was I voted for Gary Johnson saw
betrayal over Karen and then in the
final legend Oh switch over to you know
whoever is the bizarre you know the
closest to freedom thank you sir
Ron Paul why it is an unfair question
it's not fair hitting anyone I believe
in against my son know that we
hard-to-read vote against my son how
about you and uh Rand Paul Senator Paul
agree when would you say more than I
agree with him more than any other
senator or any other candidate is that
so that's pretty easily sad but no I
vote for libertarian party candidates
quite frequently you know yes quite
frequently I do so and I don't think is
anything wrong with that matter of fact
that you know after the oh eight
primaries I had a group came together I
had the Green Party I had Ralph Nader
myself and the Libertarian Party come
together and I wanted them to start this
groundswell just vote from the
alternative we need to all get together
and matter of fact I got the four of us
to agree on some basic fundamentals like
honest fed and civil liberties and the
war policies and and the big deficit we
had all these groups from left and right
coming together so I want people to
you know because it's so unfair in the
system we go over and die and kill
people to spread democracy which is a
lot of baloney because in this country
if you're in the Libertarian Party and
American party honest you don't get a
fair shake c-span I know I got on c-span
in 1988 so you do allow you know the
other candidates to get on but you know
you don't get on the debate and you
don't get to cover agent it's and you
can't get on ballot when I ran in 88 as
a libertarian I spent a half on money
just trying to get on ballots and so
that's why I encourage it but
unfortunately I'm still back to the
whole idea of ideas have consequences so
if if the libertarian ideas are worth
its salt it will it will invade the
Republican Party the democrat party and
everybody else it will change people's
minds do you think it I don't mean to
get you in trouble at home but do you
think you'll have the opportunity to
vote for your son for president in 2016
well I think there's a very good chance
that that could happen I've depos right
now even suggest that this is our
conversation on book TV on c-span too
with author dr. congressman former
presidential candidate Ron Paul it's got
about an hour and 15 minutes left to go
in our interview but every month when we
talk to our in-depth author we like to
ask him or her what are you reading what
are some of your influences your
favorite books we're going to show you
dr. Paul's responses at this point
you
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
c---span to providing live coverage of
the US Senate floor proceedings and key
public policy events and every weekend
book TV now for 15 years the only
television network devoted to nonfiction
books and authors c-span - created by
the cable TV industry and brought to you
as a public service by your local cable
or satellite provider watch us in HD
like us on Facebook and follow us on
Twitter
here's a look at some upcoming book
fairs and festivals happening around the
country on August 30 as a book TV will
be live at the National Book Festival
the annual festival will take place at
the Washington Convention Center in
Washington DC then on September 6th the
bookmarks Festival of Books & authors
will hold their 10th annual festival in
winston-salem North Carolina the
festival is the largest of its kind in
North Carolina and features both indoor
and outdoor events on September 21st
this year's Brooklyn Book Festival will
be held at the Brooklyn Borough Hall and
plaza the festival will host more than
100 US and international authors and
from September 26th through the 28th the
annual Baltimore Book Festival takes
place at the city's Inner Harbor let us
know about book fairs and festivals in
your area and we'll add them to our list
email us at book TV at c-span org
Ron Paul you list your parents is one of
your biggest influences who were they
Howard Paul and Margaret Paul they were
both from Pittsburgh they were they met
in Lutheran Church activities one lived
in Carnegie Pennsylvania other in Mount
Washington in Pittsburgh and my dad had
a small dairy and I have four four
brothers and we sort of helped work our
way through college by being milkman and
they they had an influence on me mostly
on you know gentleness and also an
understanding of the work ethic so you
didn't expect my system we were all born
in the 30s that we've been born during
the Depression and then there's World
War two which I remember very clearly
and things were pretty depressed during
World War two because there was
rationing a lot of other dumb things the
government did so it wasn't much
prosperity until after that so but there
was a strong need for a work ethic and
we had to go out and you know deliver
our papers and deliver milk and mow our
lawns and things like that but I think
it was I think sometimes what you get
from your parents is sort of a
subtleness you know to be it was
gentleness you know it was no yelling
and screaming and beatings and even when
I did things that I should have been
doing said there wasn't you know the any
harshness and I always thought that was
a good standard to go by who's Carol
Paul Carol Paul she's she's this girl
that invited me to her birthday party
when she was 16 her dad had an an
Sylvania yeah and we went to high school
together but her dad had always promised
her a big party when she was 16 because
she was born on February 29th
so she came around and she had been sort
of you know anxious to talk to him so
she it was set up and somebody said yeah
you need to go I said that was our first
date and you've been married since since
57 how many how many
and all together with five five children
and Julia Baron are count 19
grandchildren and six
great-grandchildren
so besides Senator Rand Paul any of the
others interested in politics including
Carroll they're all interested and
supportive none of the others had ever
run for office the RAM was interested
very early you know even when I was
running for Congress he was probably you
know more eager but he was always
interested in organization one I ever
was you know I organized precincts and
was very helpful in in in the campaigns
but he was always very much involved in
that but the others are very supportive
and with campaign and and do a lot of
things no no Carol it was a great
campaign or to matter like she's very
well-known in the district you know
where we would travel a lot and be seen
but she got the same type of recognition
when I was running for president I mean
I'll tell you that the the supporters
know her as well as they know me I mean
they really know who Carol Paul is and
so she's been a big help
why did you go to med school and how
they end up in Texas well ii would first
i ended up in texas because my first
trip to texas to live there was I was
drafted I was in in the middle of my
residency at at the Henry Ford Hospital
in Detroit and the Cuban crisis came up
I was yanked out and I ended up being in
the Air Force for five years but we like
Texas when I finished my residency after
that in Pennsylvania then we then we
went back back to Texas you asked also
about how going into medicine well I
think I always wanted to do it but I was
very cautious because I never wanted to
say what I'm going to do and not be
successful so I wasn't gonna say I'm
gonna be a doctor I'm gonna be doctor
because I knew it wasn't easy and though
I wanted II you know be certain and as I
gained more confidence than I decided to
do it but there was another thing I was
very influenced by the tragedy of war
are the tragedies I knew about as a kid
from World War two friends and people
who didn't come back and Korea was the
same way and Vietnam was the same way
but one of the things that I knew even
early on that I never be able to shoot
somebody and I thought if I was a doctor
I could help people and that in the back
of my mind was always you know and I
always made the assumption I'll be
drafted and I was right
I was I was drafted you know and put
into that situation not not quite the
same situation but that was that was one
of the motivations but you know I liked
I liked science I like dealing with
people I ended up doing obstetrics
because even though it was a tough
schedule it was still a very enjoyable
part of Medicine you know bringing a new
life into the world do you estimate how
many babies you've delivered yes it's uh
it's about four thousand there many who
have delivered a lot more than that but
you know I took a leave of absence and
then Ron Paul is our guest we have a
little over an hour left in our in-depth
program for this month and we're going
to go return to your phone calls now
John's calling from Gresham Oregon John
you're on the air
thank you for c-span and thank you
Congressman Paul for your dedicated
service to our nation and you are
perhaps well actually you are the only
Republican from Texas I have any respect
for whatsoever thank you again for that
my question is with treaties and trade
agreements having the power to supersede
our Constitution mr. Paul I would like
your opinion on whether things like the
trans-pacific partnership the text
should be released for the American
public to review before any vote is ever
taken to enact or defeat such a trade
agreement and again Congressman Paul I
thank you for your service yes I mean
all this stuff should be readily
available and this day and age they can
get it out to everybody
who has an interest and then maybe they
could wake up their congressman not to
vote for these kind of things because
you know I don't like these multiple
these modal trade agreements and I don't
like the way they're devised because of
course the president has there is given
authority to negotiate these treaties
and I don't think he has it it should be
the Congress and so I think they're
they're all bad but on other treaties
I've always been annoyed by these
multilateral and unilateral military
trees how many countries have we
promised that we would go and defend if
they were ever attacked well the the
idea that it's a mutual defense treaty
is that they'll come and help us you
know yeah we have to sign treaties with
all these countries because if we're
going to be attacked they're going to
come here and help us now that's that
that's that's not that's not a let's
take for instance a treaty to defend
Taiwan what what moral right there's a
one generation 56 years ago have to sign
a treaty that commits our kids and our
tax dollars to doing whatever is
necessary to go and defend Taiwan
you know I'm sympathetic I hope nothing
ever happens to them but that treaty
should shouldn't be a proper treaty in
the moral sense and I think some of
these treaties you take the United
Nations tree they so this is a treaty
and we have to do you know we have to go
along with the rules and if they say we
have to fight a war and this sort of
thing
well these treaties they should be
challenged and of course the Supreme
Court would never rule any of these
things unconstitutional but there's way
way too many treaties of this this type
of commitment and I I just think they're
wrong Carl winger asked via email what
do you think is a single biggest cause
of government growth over the last 100
years it's a it's a philosophy it's a
philosophy of government and it's the
acceptance of interventionism
that people believe that they have to be
protected by the government the
government has a right and an obligation
to intervene to manage the economy
intervene to make us better people tell
us what we can eat drink smoke and do
whatever and that we are so smart and so
good and we are so exceptional that we
have this obligation to tell everybody
around the world how to live so this
whole whole philosophy which is opposite
of liberty interventionism is where the
government takes over and and and
cancels out all your liberty so it is
this acceptance of intervention ISM that
promotes big government then they work
in collusion with paying for the
government that is borrowing to the hilt
taxed to the hilt and then we don't have
enough just print the money and then you
end up in a mess like we have today
Jerian Ann Arbor asks via email does Ron
Paul think we should do anything about
climate change why am i would like to
send him I'd like them send me some
warmer weather to Texas though I've had
a frost at home for the last five years
I'm tired of it my fruit trees were
freezing this last winter is terrible we
had a cold winter and made to see we
grow like never before our seaweed on
our beaches are three feet high and they
said it's because the water is too cold
so I'm looking forward to the day we get
a little bit warmer weather we're having
a cool summer too so no we a little bit
you could do is I don't like to deal
with say I can change the climate
because you can't change the climate per
se but you could deal something with
pollution pollution is a violation of
property rights and for too long big
business and governments did in
collusion together to allow allow
pollution and right now our military's a
big polluter all you have to do is go to
Iraq and look at the burn pits and all
the carbons that were Brant and all the
things going on so governments when I
lived in Pittsburgh as a kid we had the
worst skies and the worst water in the
world but that in that affected our city
and it was finally cleaned up without
the EPA
you shouldn't have a right to pollute
your neighbor's property but this whole
idea I think if anybody serious about
worrying about dry global warming they
need to look at some of the statistics
over the last 100 years because it's far
from conclusive you have a 15 year
period of temperatures gradually getting
warmer and then a 15-year periods
gradually getting colder and maybe a
half a degree here and there
I think it's way overblown but I don't
think you should ignore pollution in the
air and I think you can solve most of
those problems with property rights but
storms will come and go and you're going
to have her skipper earthquakes and
hurricanes and volcanoes for a long time
to come and you ought to compare what a
big volcano does to our atmosphere
compared to some other thing but I think
we need soonest what what what I don't
like about it is if you don't say oh yes
mankind has to be reined in mankind is
destroyed this world and it's coming to
an end I think that's a bit over the top
because the evidence isn't quite there
and and they say no if you don't if you
don't endorse global warming you're
sometime of a political atheist and you
deserve to be crucified and it's a
religion for some people I think they
need to you know calm down a little bit
on that because I think they they are
using it as a tool to promote you know
their agenda and and this whole idea
that government has to solve this
problem
I think governments are so often you
know contributor to the cause I mean
these people who are doing the preaching
they heather most of time they have
their own private jet flying around they
don't seem to curtail their own
activities and if they really want to
work on it they ought to work on
government pollution you know before
they closed on industry jim vancouver
washington please go ahead with your
question or comment good day gentlemen
dr. paul i'd like to thank you for your
service and my question to you
is I've been doing some reading about a
financial credit rating that our nation
holds I didn't know that which I wasn't
aware of this but that our financial
rating could be downgraded and
precipitated sale of foreign owned debt
via the Chinese Saudi Arabia is
something like that
what do you know about that and how does
that really relate to us well it has
been downgraded one time but it's been
totally ignored because we still are the
kingpin we have the military might we
still have most of the wealth but it has
been downgraded it can get downgraded
again and the there's been a little bit
of a move in that direction
of foreign holders of our debt and in
the recent weeks when I've looked at
these statistics and shows that there's
been a little bit of selling with China
and some other countries and our Federal
Reserve has been buying more but not too
long ago there were some statistics
showing that maybe Russia might have
sold a lot of the bonds because they
were threatening it would be confiscated
and it looks like all of a sudden Brazil
Bolivia ended up buying a whole lot of
it and they didn't there was no way
believe it had to be the shenanigans of
the Fed extending some credit and
telling it and buy up these bonds
because we don't want our balance sheet
to look so bad no that's the big that's
the big issue it's unpredictable about
when the momentum will build and they
will lose control of it right now
they've been able to so-called manage it
but it's also the reason they haven't
gotten out of a recession because it's
hanging over our heads and the debt
problem is the one problem that they
have not solved and they can't solve
under today's conditions well you're not
in government anymore so I don't think
you have to answer this question but
Andy sends it an email where does Ron
Paul keep his money stocks bonds gold
real estate or under the mattress
sure well I think I mentioned these
things over the
over the many years I had an investment
letter one time and everybody knows I
talk about golden I hate paper I I've
always favored real assets you know
something that government can't redo
placate you know so hey I was off as a
kid I was raised saving silver silver
coin each you know thought I was a coin
collector and then when I started
studying the money issue and I really
enjoyed saving silver coins and and then
and then gold coin but when I was a kid
you weren't even allowed down gold coins
it was illegal and we only got the legal
right to own gold in 1976 so Lea
Roosevelt made it illegal in 1933
because he he run it took all the gold
in at $20 an ounce and he made it $35 an
ounce the people out of the appreciation
of the the gold dollar value so I think
I'm in gold if you ever if you worry
about paper money say buy a little gold
a little silver I think the stock market
you know a couple days ago they had me
quoted a newspaper
Ron Paul thinks there's a stock market
bubble next two days the market out 414
they really are watch it now I think I
think the stocks the stocks are terrible
place to have your pudding but that's my
opinion and the ones who have been in
tomorrow and they made a lot of money
doing this they've kidded me on TV you
know and I say yeah one we understand
you would buy gold and this sort of
thing you were interested when gold was
$35 an ounce and they said yeah but just
think of all the time you all the money
you lost didn't make it in the regular
stock market matter yeah and that gold
at $35 an ounce that was a dumb trick
now they're worth $1,500 you know no I
think I think real assets are good I
think property is good
I think stocks or bonds or what dog to
make any interest so I I think all that
is important and then I try to practice
good habits on that but you know what
the bottom line is if you're a
survivalist you
golden silver you have a gun you have
food and you know you're ready and you
have a Haven someplace to go to but none
of it's worth anything if you don't have
your freedom and that is why I invest
every bit as much free and that's my
biggest investment is investing in
promoting the cause of Liberty for me
personally my benefit for me to live in
a free society and for my family and
everybody in America to have freedom
because that's the only investment that
really counts because you know
governments are big and they have a lot
of guns and no matter how how immoral
and wrong the IRS is they're very
powerful and they've been they've abused
their power for a long time and they
frightened me
you know and right now in fact we have
an organization campaign for liberty and
they're hounding us and they're
threatening us and they're threatening
close us down and take the money out of
our checking account because we wouldn't
turn over names of the people who
donated and yet their Supreme Court
ruling say we don't have to turn over
the names in this organization and so
it's it's if that's the investment that
we should all be involved in educate
ourselves educate your friends and
neighbors try to promote good government
but if we don't live in a free society
I'll tell you what your your guns aren't
going to be enough to you know protect
us I mean it might help now and then you
know against gangsterism but right now
right now we have to address the subject
of a runaway government two quotes from
two different books this is freedom
under siege 1987 a right is a natural or
god-given permit received at birth to
act in one's own self-interest with
total control over one's own life and
liberty as long as others are not
injured nor their property taken or
damaged and to follow that up with the
Liberty defined book from 2011 in a free
society individuals are allowed to be
creeps and pick and choose all their
associations that is they can
discriminate even when the majority
disapproves
of their choices that's the hard one for
a lot of people but but most people
accept our first amendment
you know the first amendment says that
the government can't write any laws
about our speech which means that we can
criticize our government and we can say
things and we can say controversial
things and I always say to make the
point that the First Amendment isn't
there because it isn't there to regulate
you know talking about whether it's
there to regulate and permit
controversial speech so controversial
personal practices should be legal too
this protects everybody no matter what
your personal beliefs are you might be
very very liberal or very very
conservative and you might have
different reasons to want your Liberty
and you want the government out of your
life and that's why I believe you should
be able to bring liberals and
conservatives together to defend Liberty
and even though we might use our Liberty
difference but there are some rules in
here and it's the non-aggression and
both both of them emphasize the
non-aggression principle is that you
can't address against your neighbor you
can't initiate force here we have a
government initiating force against
other nation but you can't initiate
force and if you if you had that then
you don't can't take property you can't
take a person's property and it would be
a it would be a wonderful perfect world
if everybody followed this but right now
we have a government that doesn't follow
it and that's that's where the real
problem is because there's confiscation
of wealth and abusive regulations and
micromanaging our personal activities
and our personal associations all life
is made up on discrimination everything
we do is making a choice am I going to
be here am I gonna be here but all of a
sudden people want to get into this
micromanaging of what we do with our
personal lives right now one thing that
I have a little struggle with and I'm
going to work on is this obsession with
political correctness because the
libertarian would say well you know if
if I'm a businessman and I'm
real goofball the libertarian man sees
his boycott him see the boycotts during
the civil civil rights movement was
great
boycott him and emphasizes don't don't
do it don't subsidize them so you should
be able to do that but what happens when
when everybody gangs up on you didn't do
and you didn't do anything illegal you
just didn't have good common sense and
did something very impolite that
everybody from government people down to
everybody in the media piles on until
they lose their property they lose their
job and they could go bankrupt because
of it it seems like this there should be
a limit but I don't know where that
would be because I'm such a free spirit
that you want to allow people to do what
they want but there are conditions which
it looks like political correctness is
getting around the First Amendment that
if we you know outside a government if
we bear down and punish that person you
know it'll be good but I would always
lean toward the side of saying that the
government shouldn't be involved in when
people do things that are goofy even
even if they don't deserve to be
punished if they said something stupid
if if people are so obsessed with trying
to punish them and show how good they
are most of the time when they do this I
think the people who come down hardest
on individuals who spoke in discreetly
and said something I think the people
who come down on them are probably very
insecure themselves with these issues
and they have to prove how saintly they
are and that's why they bear it on on
these people and they want to destroy
them well from 1987 on individual rights
you write employee rights are said to be
valid when employers pressure employees
into sexual activity
why don't they quit once the so-called
harassment starts obviously the morals
of the harasser cannot be defended but
how can the harass II escape some
responsibility for the problem seeking
protection under civil rights
legislation is hardly acceptable the
depth paragraph gets you in any trouble
well I'm sure there's plenty
there would say not ask that's too much
freedom they're going on on that but no
voluntary contracts everything is
voluntary so if you're the businessman
and I am the employee and I decide to
work for you and you tell me what the
rules are I have to live up to them if
you if if you injure me then I have a
right of record but if you just annoy me
and bug me and and do things and offend
me I should quit you know because you
can't keep me there you can't force me
or I'd be a slave if I don't if I can't
leave you know I mean I should have the
right to leave and I think that there
wouldn't be a need for a federal
policemen to come in and try to settle
these things I just think that the
voluntary contract and and the
non-aggression principle can deal with
this that if you aggressively hurt
people and in this this doesn't have to
wait till somebody socks you in the nose
because if there is a threat of force if
people come and point a gun at you have
to wait till they shoot you you know you
have a right to defend yourself so but
but I think the bureaucrats aren't
capable of sorting these things out
Jeremiah Moss Beach California you are
on book TV on c-span 2 with Ron Paul
it's an honor to speak with you doctor
you're a great statement a wonderful
patriot my question of all social
security ever since the protections got
watered down
Congress it's been a bipartisan slush
fund and I don't understand why they
Congress allowed all these public
retirement funds to not pay into Social
Security my answer if I had the powers
if every American worker contributed a
small amount Social Security would be
solvent tomorrow because I have your
your thoughts please
I guess he's referring to contribute
money to bail out the public pension
funds you think they're bunch of pension
well I I'd have to get a further
understanding of this but most of those
programs should shouldn't exist but if
you had well I can it's easier to talk
about a pension fund say for the
military you know you have somebody in
the military for 10 or 20 years and we
have a contract with them we have to pay
for them well the money should be saved
I mean we should be our books should be
balanced
we shouldn't have deficits we shouldn't
have you know welfare being run a lot of
times you know we have funds you know
the the user fee type of fund isn't the
worst idea as an interim you know the
Highway Trust Fund for instance it
shouldn't be there but if it is it
should be honored but what happens is
you have these trust funds whether it's
Social Security or highway trust funds
that money gets taken it's immediately
put into the cash fund and that money is
spent you know on a militarism and other
things so if it's it's the whole system
of government of overspending and I
think these pension funds I think you're
only seeing the beginning of this
whether they're local government funds
but even nationally I don't think I
think there will be a comment on that
you're going to see some real trouble in
Social Security and all the pension
funds Kirra my next call is from
Stephanie in Alger Michigan Stephanie
please go ahead hi dr. Paul I am a 30
year old nurse was seven years
experience I've recently decided to
further my education and I've been
considering either becoming a nurse
practitioner a biomedical engineer or
leaving healthcare altogether to enter
electrical engineering my question is do
you think with all the government
intervention and regulation within
healthcare including the medical device
tax can healthcare again become a
prosperous industry in the future or do
you think now is a good time to cut ties
and exit healthcare well I think it
depends on how devoted you are to
participating in medicine both because
of what you say good you can do with it
and also if you you know enjoy it and
enjoy doing it and I you know we have
our five five children we have three
physicians but I never went out of my
way to encourage them to do it and I
think they all went into the medicine
for for the right reason but there was a
lot of hesitation you know it's going to
get worse you know and and medicine
today is so much more difficult and
bureaucratic and that was when I started
you know so it's very very difficult and
besides if you leave one field do you
think you're going to be free from some
of the obstacles that you face there but
indeed with Obamacare and this taxing
things can get much much worse so no I
would I wouldn't tell people not to do
and I think it should be weighed on are
you really going to get some personal
enjoyment out of changing right now I
and also there's this if we can keep the
right to do things privately you know if
you can opt out there's always going to
be a place for for people to work and
even even in medicine today it's it's
being shaky and they're trying to take
that away from us but know that'll be a
personal decision on you on your part
but you'll have to decide whether you
want to risk you know going into a
completely different field
tisha tweets in to you dr. Paul
what can the next generation of people
who want to defend liberty and politics
do to be effective
well first they need to understand the
freedom philosophy what Liberty is all
about where it comes from in what it
really means and understand that they
understand it well enough to be able to
explain it because all because they will
meet the demagogues believe me if you're
a free market person you hate poor
people and you will let them starve in
the street and never give them any
medicine not realizing that it is the
welfare system and the socialist system
where people end up not having enough to
and not having a good medical care so it
is understanding that and realizing that
freedom is controversial because you you
allow a lot of activities that seem to
be immoral and people will be critical
and say oh you mean you'd let people
smoke marijuana cigarettes oh this is
this is horrible you don't want to do
that but you have to remember that if
you legalize something a lot of people
make their own choice it doesn't mean
you endorse the activity and that's a
big difference
it's it's if you understand this then
the people aren't frightened by it and I
think studying understanding it
believing in it and knowing how to
answer the negative comments about it
because they're very serious and people
who care about people how they're doing
you know morally well we've got to make
these people better morally and we have
to make sure nobody starves in the
street so if you understand that and
then what you do after that is it's
going to be up to the individuals
everybody's going to have a chance I
mean I think if a person is in teaching
or journalism on TV teaching y'all
anything or start an organization we run
for office it depends on the individual
and I get the ask the question so often
on a college campus they say what should
I do
I think whatever you want to do do what
you want and but know what you're
talking about know what the philosophy
is and knowing how wonderful it is and
know and find out how untested it's been
we've had such a short period time if
you look at all recorded history of
thousands of years it's only been you
know a couple hundred years where they
really talked about you know personal
liberty industrialization of our of our
world and the improvement of society
it's just been a short period of time
everything else has been
authoritarianism the individual wasn't
important and so I think we've only had
a little taste we had a great period of
time in our early history it was
fantastic more Liberty more prosperity
than anyplace else in the world and now
we've given up on it so but I think that
we can keep moving
in the right direction moving as long as
we know what the principles are and that
people are talked into endorsing these
principles and they shouldn't be
intimidated by the demagogues in the
pendant and the people who pump out the
war propaganda why we have to always go
to war you know to save the world or we
always have to raise the taxes in order
to make sure that the middle class is
doing well at the same time realizing
we're destroying the middle class and
making the poor poorer and all we're
doing is rewarding the rich when they
realize that then they will have to find
a job before we got started you
mentioned that people under 25 are more
likely to recognize you than people who
are 55 yes at least they're they're more
likely to come up to me maybe some of
the others are good but maybe if they're
35 or 40 or 50 maybe they're more
reserved they might recognize a token
but the young people will come up to me
and you know and they're always you know
very very polite I just I just think you
know there's a lot of talk about oh the
younger generation alterable they are
and they'll show you some pictures of
you know the wild things that they do
but I'll tell you what the ones that
come up to our rallies and our meetings
I am really impressed I am that's what
gives me I hope that we do have a
generation very interested in these
issues that we've been talking about
they've already studied them and they're
already very engaged I mean I have I
have kids that you know are 14 years old
and they're dragging their parents
dragged their parents to my
congressional office
it was a kids that wanted to come in and
I'd look at it they would know about the
Federal Reserve and they're reading all
about this I said how holding them 14
years old
well I didn't even have the vaguest idea
what was going on when I was 14 let
alone what they're doing so they're very
very engaged and that's why we shouldn't
be too pessimistic about what's
happening Christopher tweets in do you
broadcast the c-span book TV channel in
HD if not why not
Christopher yes we do broadcast in HD
and then several systems across the
country are caring
that signal in HD it's up to each
individual system so thanks for that
Charles in Georgia is it sauteed Micucci
Georgia Charles that is correct
okay just go ahead with your question or
comment for Ron Paul dr. Paul I followed
you throughout the 2012 primaries and
you want every debate you were head and
shoulders above all the other candidates
and everybody I know voted for you but I
don't think our votes were any good
due to she's my little nurse due to
computer fraud that's the only way I can
explain why you didn't win every primary
caucus and your idea of having delegates
to go down was good but they changed the
rules on you so what you comment on that
so I think you're pretty close to being
on target the rules did get changed and
and you know there were several states
where it was very blatant and they just
refused to you know have our delegates
go they were they were very very very
frightened they wouldn't you know this
is say I had six states or something I
mean they were so so cautious that they
even had to work very hard to make sure
none of those were were counted so yes
you know the process is very
questionable but that's unfortunately
the way so much of the politics are I
said you know from the very first race I
ever ran that we had some shenanigans
going on and I think it's too common but
so I I tend to agree with what you were
saying David Fairfax Virginia here in
the suburbs hi David
hello um dr. ball first I like this
style I like a lot of other callers have
set up for bring me to the Liberty
movement used to be a huge
neoconservative before a winch
Afghanistan and then after I came back
start reading about you and then your
views seem to be the only thing only one
that made sense from all politicians I
read about but on my question today as a
libertarian
I'm also believe in the non-aggression
principle
and one question that comes up a lot
when I'm talking people out
libertarianism that I haven't actually
been able to answer very well is on
about taxation in general because the
way I see it and the way many people see
is that taxation taxation I would say is
a um a a form of aggression since you
know you have to force someone to give
you money that isn't doing it
voluntarily but however you do right
into the paradox that the government at
some point needs income of some sort
even if it was a very small government
so how would you I'll reply to that as
far as how the government would receive
income versus well in in a more perfect
system if we can scrap what we have and
we were devising it I wouldn't have an
income tax certainly the Constitution
permits um taxation but I would move in
the direction of a user tax so if you
want government to be involved in
highways the people who drive on the
highways you know a gasoline tax but
make sure that all the money collected
goes there and not off into some other
welfare program so a user tax is a good
idea along our Gulf Coast we have the
intercostal canal and it takes a lot of
maintenance and the people who use the
canal they pay a lot of money to use it
but then they have to that money gets
spent and then they have to come back
and lobby to get the Congress to
appropriate the money to take care of
the the intercostal canal so no use user
fees or good ideas I know it's far far
from perfect but you know the most
popular bumper sticker that I had I was
on my desk for a long time and I still
use it and that is it says don't steal
the government hates competition and and
I think taxation in many ways this
stealing especially when it's for the
redistribution of wealth and I would say
probably about 80% of it is
redistributing it from one group to
another and unfortunately it isn't going
to the people who really need to help we
pretend that it's being redistributed to
help the poor but it's redistributing it
to hell
that very very wealthy group that are
able to manipulate the Federal Reserve
System in the financial system in the
military system you've said you won't
run for president again could you see
yourself running for Congress again now
you know I've done that a few times and
matter of IQ did read that a little bit
but I'm going to have to brag just a
little bit on one thing because I don't
know how many have done it because you
know you can't beat incumbents you know
even though as much as they complain
about Congress incumbents or you know
are pretty secure it's starting to shift
now with the Tea Party you know everyone
so we see incumbents losing but I ran in
two different periods of time and two
times I'd be the incumbent so it was a
challenge but no I'm not going to go for
the another record say I beat an
incumbent - third time no I'm very
content to do what I'm doing now and if
if people want to pay a little attention
that's good with me but actually I never
really expected to get very much
attention I didn't expect to get elected
and then I thought well if I talk about
what I really believe in they won't
elect me and I was pleasantly surprised
and then I thought well what if I vote
this way all the time
well they surely won't that means I'd
have to vote against a lot of stuff from
a district well I got re-elected then
too so I I just I'm not really ready to
do that I'm not going to do that again
but I will keep trying to spread a
message and I thought that I would be
just setting a record in Washington you
know that even if it had to be one or
two or three you know by myself the one
record I have there is haven't voted by
myself more than everybody else put
together but then I thought it was just
to set a record and somebody some day
later we go back and and look at it and
say you know we hear about this guy went
how he voted and have a you know and
interested in this particular philosophy
and I was thinking in the distant future
that I would quietly go about my
business and make my statements and go
by but but
then something happened about six years
ago and all of a sudden I think there
was an explosion of interest in what's
going on the economy crashed the wars
went badly and I was more visible you
know in the presidential races so the
reception changed a lot from what I had
expected
Cynthia Virginia City Nevada good
afternoon Oh dr. Paul it's wonderful to
see you in such vibrant good health I
was one of those national delegates from
Nevada who unbound and voted for you at
Tampa when you were denied your
nomination speech right now the RNC has
in place draconian rules for electing
delegates to the National Convention the
winner of the primaries in each state
will be able to handpick the national
delegates circumventing the grassroots
we've been trying very hard to change
that rule which wasn't even passed by
the majority at that convention if you
watch the video you hear the huge
majority of knows oh what can those of
us working within the GOP do about this
we've had no luck or success that's far
at the RNC meetings well I think I have
to do more of what you're doing letting
us know about that and you have
first-hand experience in investing and
you know what that they were doing but
yeah they just flat-out change the rules
and the interesting thing is if it's a
worthwhile effort because you know they
talk about the Ron Paul people thinking
no we they were being punished and it
was directed at them I don't want any
any Ron Paul people doing this again but
you know there were a lot who weren't
considered they weren't in that category
they weren't part of our organization
but they were part of a decent
conservative wing of the party that
could see the same thing you just
described it was under my name the
grassroots so there's a big coalition
you point out they didn't even have the
vote they didn't force the vote so I
would say that the people you know
between now and the convention time
there has to be a lot of grassroots
effort which is a real
really tough German has to be done
individually in local communities in
each state in order to get the people to
these to these conventions in order to
get these rules changed but there was a
little bit of publicity on this when the
rules were changed but no they need more
people to do exactly what you're doing
and I know you keep doing with what you
are by calling in and getting this
information out so Ron Paul after the
2012 convention in Tampa you held your
last big rally down there are very big
rally at the University of Southern
Florida did the Romney campaign reach
out to you did you endorse him did you
speak for him was it just passi I would
say no no I don't they I mean I met and
I got along real well and it was
politics involved but there I sort of
you know we didn't have to talk about
poly I sort of liked him you know
because you know he had a large family
at one son that was in medical school
and mrs. Romney was very nice and she
going real well with Carroll and so so
on a social sense we did but politically
it was it was a different story I mean
we just had such strong disagreement but
it was also strategy for his part to you
know to at least on the surface be as
friendly as possible because we had a
significant amount some people thinks it
was very significant a number of
Delegates we have so they're not going
to yell and scream and and curse at us
you know because it would have been good
good politics and that means that you
know ideas have consequences and and
even if they don't want you they have to
recognize and that was part of the
reason during the campaign the Romney
campaign wanted to sort of appease as a
bit and they asked a Boehner to call up
the vote on audit the Fed bill which was
my bill is a big issue and brought up
the floor and we wanted overwhelmingly
and all the Republicans supported it and
you know this was an idea but I saw this
as a victory in ideology you know
because it was a good issue
because openness in the financial system
was it was a good idea but as far as
speaking no I don't think I would have
been difficult for me you know because
because we wouldn't have been able and
it would have been difficult you know
for him to expect that - because we had
such strong disagreements on on foreign
policy you know and and in the the point
of civil liberties and NSA and CIA he
his beliefs in the CIA was much stronger
than mine
Larry Barnsdall Oklahoma you are on book
TV with Ron Paul well I still have my
ron paul bumper sticker on my truck and
i'm never going to take it off i
appreciate you
my question is about the constitution
itself the treaty clause seems to be the
way that the big government takes
advantage of the people by making
contracts with the people for example
the birth certificate our parents trade
a tax exemption to sell us into slavery
and we never know about it until it's
way too late and I believe that fraud if
the right word is vidiots
all contracts so we need to become more
aware of these contracts that we've made
with the government or someone has made
them on our behalf and just remove our
consent get out of the contract so the
government doesn't have any legitimacy
any longer
thank you sir well we talked a little
bit about this before and that's right
because the the treaties are a dangerous
way to amend the Constitution that's
literally what they do you sign you sign
the treaty and they say well the treaty
is the law of the land now what if the
treaties with the United Nations and you
go to war under UN resolution well you
shouldn't be able to do that and it
should be able and the courts should
deal with this it should be taken and it
should be thrown out but even engaging
in the
these treaties undermines our
sovereignty I don't need like the
treaties at all but when it literally
repeals something in the Constitution
that's not the way the Constitution
should be amended it was meant to be
event it in a much different manner
Liyana bree-zay on our Facebook page
asks and finding myself more distant
from government involvement in general
is it healthy to think like an anarchist
or what are your views on anarchy I
think if somebody is an anarchist and
they totally believe in in no government
and they don't use force at the moment
to go and start shooting up the
government's that we don't have any
government that would be wrong but to be
an anarchist and assume responsibility
for yourself I think this is a great
idea and there's a lot of people there's
a lot of very close friends of mine who
think political actions terrible and
what it's worth look I happen to be one
that believes that education is probably
paramount but political action can be
very helpful and sometimes political
action in my elections and things and in
galvanizing interests is a measurement
of our success on our ideas so I think
this is a is very important but anarchy
is is uh it's not harmful to me it's as
long as you especially if you give up
one if you're a true libertarian you've
rejected to use of force I don't have to
worry about you but if you don't if you
don't want to your biggest problem of
being an anarchist in the government
that doesn't agree with you is that well
I want to opt out they're going to come
with guns but you know we do have
incidents where some people do get to
opt out and you know when you think
about the Amish and the Mennonites I
guess I think they get exempted they
like to it just think those groups why
couldn't all of us have that opportunity
look we voluntarily want to get out and
we don't want to we want to take care of
ourselves either an individual should be
allowed to do that get no benefits from
from the government
or a group can do this a libertarian
society actually gives full permission
for socialism voluntary socialism you
know if you want to get together and
there's been a you know experiments
without in our history
you can voluntary socialism if you go
together and you agree and we're running
this community large smaller whatever on
a social scheme you should be allowed to
but we should be allowed you know to
stay out of that but the problem is it's
so inefficient that the Socialists know
their system is going to fail so they
have to use the force of a government
gun to take money from the people who
aren't socialists in order to subsidize
their program but libertarianism gives
full legal protection of anybody who
wants to have voluntary socialism but
socialists never will endorse the idea
of you having your personal liberty
where you can take care of yourself and
not ask for nothing from anybody else if
you were to recommend one of your books
for people which one would you recommend
well I think probably liberties you find
because it goes over fifty issues and
most people have specific questions you
know about these I think they get more
out of that
of course if somebody's interested in
monetary issues you know and the Fed and
the revolution book is sort of you know
one that it talks about what was going
on back in a eight you know with the
first campaign because that was actually
when the Tea Party movement started but
nobody nobody remembers that is started
in oh seven you know you know on Tea
Party Day I think as December 17th or
something you know and that is when it
really started spontaneously with our
campaign but soon it morphed into
something else because the Republicans I
hate this is a this is a movement so we
better get a little bit of control of
this thing and make sure they're not non
interventionist so so that's a mixed bag
now but then the revolution book goes
over you know a general philosophy on it
defend of course or the end of fan is
monetary and but the fifth
the Liberty defying goes over to each
individual item so you can you can sort
of go through the index oh yeah I want
to know when II thinks about this and it
wouldn't take you too long to find
something controversial in there and say
hey he's he's knots on this issue are
you working on a book early in many ways
yes I've done an outline I've written I
put some work into it
and I can't get it quite concluded I
hopefully in the next several months I
can and it's it's going to it's a book
about you never would guess it's going
to be a book just on war of the issue of
war and why peace is better than more I
attended the title I made on it was
swords into plowshares which tells the
story you know of why can't we have an
advancement in civilization where we go
from the assumption that we will always
have Wars and move into a period of time
where why can't we use all this energy
and advancement of civilization to work
work please think of what has happened
technologically in 200 years about the
amazing things that's happened
technologically everything from energy
to bombs and planes but most of the time
it's always been used to make more and
more efficient kill more people and why
can't we use the intellectual
advancement of society in a social
advancement where all of a sudden we
started using this for peace and I'm of
the belief it's conceivable that you
could usher in a whole age where all of
civilization would but you would have to
move in the direction of the person that
talked about you no no no government to
talk about less government because
governments are the ones that start the
war the one story I kill in in the book
is that about world war two we had
cousins that were in a military and and
they were overseas fighting we still at
relatives in Germany so we as kids were
taught to pray for our relatives that
they don't get killed in the war
and our cousins ended up in prison camp
so here we are trying to kill them we're
praying for them not to get killed and
it just doesn't make any sense at all
you know and I must have been less than
ten I was ten when the war was over and
I was close to my grandmother who was
very German and I must been talking to
her about it and she says you know what
she says the people don't want war
because hurt the people were still her
relatives you know I relative of that
she says the people don't want war it's
only the government's and think about it
as pretty profound because even today a
lot of people believe this
it is the government's that get us in
the trouble people don't all of a sudden
live peacefully say oh let's go have a
war you know it doesn't happen that way
they have to be they have to be built up
to have a Hitler to to challenge Saddam
Hussein he's Hitler now Putin is Hitler
and that changes the atmosphere builds
up the war propaganda and I people need
to to understand that and I think
there's there's room right now for the
recognition and I try to do that in this
book that may or may not come to
recognize that we live in a special age
we sit where were witnessing something
fantastic and that is the worst the 20th
century has shown us the total failure
of governments government wars think of
a World War one the war to end all wars
it was the war to end all peace a
totally useless worthless senseless war
they gave us World War two it's been
going on and on but I think now it's
recognized that government's running
Wars makes no sense and intervention is
economics and paper money makes no sense
and now we have this wonderful
opportunity to have a new system which
would be more advanced than anything
we've ever had before and we have the
ability to spread these ideas you know
with a tool that we've never had
or it was slow-moving and thinking
what's happen
technologically what has happened in 200
years with with a slow movement of
technology but now in the social sense
of ideas you know these ideas can move
more quickly than ever before and I am
convinced to people more like my grounds
it don't want Wars the military don't
want words I don't know if you remember
but you know during the campaign I got
more money from the military then all
the rest put together in a one-man that
called in he said he had been in
Afghanistan and converted and came over
from a neocon so they're the ones who
are involved and they had it I was I was
in the military in 1965 when to escalate
in Vietnam and I had gone into the
reserves and gone back to my residency
the last thing I'm in the military the
last thing I want is my government to
expand the war the war made no sense
anyway in the military they're very good
people they're good military people and
I actually you know I could rationalize
say well I'll have to be able to defend
my country and this thing but they they
go in for good purpose but they
recognize as fast as anybody that these
wars make no sense and I think this is a
I think there's a major sea change in
this but we still have you know lots of
problems that we don't have a Soviet
system the Soviet system collapsed we
don't have to fight them the American
system is going to collapse we're not
we're in too many countries and we've
abused our privileges way too much and
our dollar is in tough shape so we are
ripe for some very very great things to
happen in this country as long as we
keep their eye on the ball and all has
to do with our individual liberty where
it came from and why it's important and
why self respect and self responsibility
can solve the problems that governments
have only made worse for hundreds if not
thousands of years Ron Paul William
McMinnville Tennessee you are on the air
yes dr. Paul yes it is a it is a
pleasure and an honor to speak to you
when I was 20 years old 1988 I catch
mother for you as a libertarian and you
kind of lit my fire into the 90s I
campaigned for Andre Rieu and Harry
Brown who was close to us in Tennessee
and I just really appreciate the
inspiration you gave me through the 90s
80s 90s and I just want to ask you a
question so many questions of the
answers by the previous colors and your
answers to them especially about social
anarchism you know as Emma Goldman said
I will not rule and I will not be ruled
but to cut it short like I told your
screener I'd like to ask you what you
think about Thomas Jefferson's quotes of
if the country should go more than 20
years with out of violent uprising of
the people the Republic is lost and
another quote the tree of liberty must
be watered from time to time with the
blood of tyrants and with the
military-industrial complex which came
with being in the 50s I know that
impossible would just be suicide for
American people to for militias but just
your thoughts on his ideas all right I
mean we got the point okay I guess that
you have never heard me use that quote
from Jefferson probably won't because it
wouldn't be one of my favorite favorite
quote he he has a point there that you
have to fight for your liberties and you
have to reestablish it but there's a
little bit too much bloodletting in
those quotes so my personality and all
just doesn't lean in that direction I
think you have to renew the spirit of
Liberty and build on it and improve on
it but I lean much closer to a Gandhi
approach you know them than I do that
you have to have blood and you have to
shoot and you have to change things then
I think I recognize how powerful ideas
are and resistance is very good
and I met might be my personality I just
like I said I became a doctor because I
never wanted to carry a gun and shoot
somebody and I want a revolution and I'm
fighting for that I write about it and
and it's high on my agenda but my
revolution is is not with the need of
violence but I do believe in
self-defense I mean if as much as
nonviolent person as I am if somebody
came into my household but my family
threatened me I believe that I would
have the moral right and obligation to
use lethal force but but still I think
when it comes to politics I sort of like
what Martin Luther King did with
non-violence he said he preached that
and I think I was good as well as Gandhi
I mean he was taking on the British
Empire and it's a it's it's my personal
way of doing it but and I'm always
hoping that my views could prevent the
need you know for a violent overthrow
just a few minutes left with our guest
David and Cincinnati here hi dr. Paul
thanks for taking my call
I'm a pre-med student and I used to work
in ER and my question concern medical
toward reform and liberty and I'm sure
you're well aware that physicians today
are practicing defensive medicine for
fear of getting malpractice lawsuit and
that studies have shown that they're
ordering diagnostic tests not
necessarily to the benefit of the
patient but really just recover if their
own back that's directly rising raising
health care cost however I've talked to
legal scholars on the matter who say
that tort reform is difficult because it
may impede the right to a fair trial and
I was just wanting to be had any
thoughts on that well yes I have and
I've worked with some legislation on
this and I believe that you can find the
answer in the free market but
governments prevent us from a free
market solution to this but you should
be able to contract with patients the
doctors should be able to contract if
something goes wrong that there would be
an arbitrator and that there may
be even an insurance policy that would
guarantee this there could be an
insurance policy for an obstetrician for
the care of a woman for nine months and
no matter what happens you know that
insurance should take care of all the
problems and it wouldn't be
confrontational we don't we don't go to
court and fight it out when there's
insurance with our automobiles so in
medicine you could do that but the
problem is the contracts aren't
legitimate they throw the contracts out
and say that the patient has the right
to sue and they have the right to do
this and you can't you can't get them to
sign something to say that they wouldn't
sue you but if but if they would agree
to the arbitration and how it would be
handle it would be a solution to do it
but but right now it is a real mess and
some of the specialties OB is one
announces all the other the the rates
are so high and as bad as that problem
is as strong as I felt about this we had
some people come up and write national
laws dictating to the states what they
could do it I couldn't support it
because I didn't like the vehicle but
they think the federal government should
be involved but some states have done a
better job than some of the tort law has
been improved in Texas and other places
but it could be solved in the free
market by allowing contracts faughn
Encino California you are on the air
hello Paul it's good to see you thank
you and I want to say you look great for
79 absolutely wonderful 79 and and it's
good to see you Peter you're looking
wonderful my question is I'm going to
get on the race situation since
President Obama has been in office it
seems like the country pull it so hard
and a lot of racial tension has emerged
again do you feel that this racial
tension has always been there but it
just morphed in a different way and
simmer down for a while until President
Obama
was elected and came into office and
also one more thing before you got me on
Peter on what do you think honestly I
feel that that it has always been sort
of a racial undertow in the country
anyway and that's something that just
has to disappear I just I feel that it
just emerged again and it morphed more
since President Obama has he came into
office but there are a lot of things I'm
a more of a balanced person so if I say
that I'm if I speak sort of balanced
people think that I'm more on a
Republican side and then if I speak more
of social things they think I'm more a
Democrat well I'm neither democrat or
republican so but I do feel that it's
just so much tension that has to be
released out of the country in order to
make a more that say a country with the
liberty and justice for all
all right thank you fun and in fact in
Liberty defined you have a whole chapter
on racism right not not an easy problem
on to deal with now I think there is is
the racism that exists and I think if
our conditions were very good in the
country was thriving and Obama was in
charge of a libertarian society and we
were having no problems it would be a
lot less there would always be some
racial sentiment against the president
no matter how well we were doing but
when things go badly those individuals
who have a racial tendency you know they
actually give them you know an excuse to
do this so I think it's sort of related
to to what's happening I and I've made
the comments about some of the problems
about our borders that you know it's the
economy that leads to our trouble at the
borders if we were doing well it
wouldn't be an issue but because we're
doing so badly and
you have to find something to blame much
of this stuff and hatred about the
illegal is is is a bit of scapegoating
and using this as an excuse but I don't
think you'll ever get rid of those
things and the only solution to me that
people have these negative sentiments is
libertarianism and exacting the
principle that you can't use force to
hurt anybody and impose your will on
other people it sort of takes care of
that and those people are totally
unimportant they have no value but to
sort all that out I don't I don't know
if anybody could tell exactly how much
of the resentment is because of race
versus what is in the economy I think I
think our society our government is in
in such bad shape and people were sick
and sick of the economy and sick and
tired of the wars and these other things
that happens that Obama is president
right now and he's an easy target but me
personally I had I I was disturbed as
much with a couple Republican presidents
I am with this one maybe because I
thought they were as they were they
would say one thing and they were doing
exactly the opposite so I resented that
every bit as much it had nothing to do
with the color of skin Carroll in
Littleton Colorado email
do you believe civil rights would have
happened without federal intervention oh
absolutely
do you mean oh oh yes because I think we
were well on our way all we had to do
was repeal all the bad laws most most of
the civil strife and the segregation
came from government all the way back to
slavery I mean that was a government
function and they should have gotten rid
of it you know from the very beginning
but but they did we segregate into the
military you know World War two in my
lifetime we had segregated military
forces the Jim Crow laws this government
so yes you repeal all that where was we
were the earliest neatest times of
integration branch rickey jackie
robinson i mean think of that you know
that was that was fantastic and no no i
think i think the way it went it turned
out to be terrible in winter these
busing arguments you know we're going to
bus and
or Sisson do this that was that was not
eliminating Jim Crow laws and then where
were the biggest rise over buffering in
Boston you know the people who did the
most preaching you know about those
terrible people in the South the busing
you know those who it now you don't need
the government do that you need people
to act voluntarily and you need to get
rid of the laws and all the things that
the government did to to promote the
segregation because it wouldn't have
happened otherwise
last call Olivia Lake Havasu City
Arizona hi Olivia
hello Thank You dr. Paul and please
continue to inspire us to be aware
involved and not become people I have
two questions one is your feelings about
agenda21
the controversy and impact on our
freedom second question our current
immigration challenge to our security
and our liberty thank you okay on agenda
21 that's UN stuff and trying to use up
more more of our sovereignty I don't
believe in the UN I don't believe we
should be in it and we wouldn't worry
about agenda 21 so that would be
dismissed in a libertarian Society now
on immigration we've talked a little bit
about that that is more more complex but
it's a it's a problem is going to be
with us it's a consequence of bad policy
bad economic policy people in this
country that wouldn't take some of the
bad jobs people from outside wanting
them in and work a weak economy and
makes people very nervous jobs are being
stolen and it it it has been a big big
problem we don't have an efficient
immigration service I think it should
have been much more efficient I think
workers should have been able to come
more easily I don't think the workers
and the people who come as illegal
people come in they should get no
subsidies you shouldn't subsidize with
free health care and free education but
we should be more generous with allowing
people to come in and work and there was
a time when that happened and it would
be a great service
- to our country and the freer we are
the more prosperous the autumn or we
would welcome people to come in and help
us out because we would be getting
wealthier and the best we have in the
borders are complicated because of of
the drug laws of drug war you know the
drug lords down there fighting and
killing with each other so this is why
I've always fought against the you know
the war on drugs because it have have
these consequences so we have a lot of
criminals on the borders and a lot of
money involved but it's not just because
there's a bunch of bad people we can't
get along with the Mexican people if
that is probably weighed on on the list
a problem it's because of bad government
policies why we have that mess on our
borders Ron Paul what's on your summer
reading list what are you currently
reading
well Robert Dreyfus right now about the
devil's game and he writes about the
middle east of the great historian about
our fallacy in our foreign policy you
know and how we go in and how we
precipitate hatred and how we've missed
misunderstood the radical Islamists that
that do exist and why it's partially our
fault
which nobody wants to hear about that
but that is that is part of the trouble
but it's a very very interesting book
Ron Paul has been our guest for the last
three hours here's a several of his many
books freedom under siege 1987 the Ron
Paul money book 1991 foreign policy of
freedom peace Commerce and honest
friendship came out in 2007 pillars of
as an aide as did the revolution a
manifesto a best-seller and and the Fed
another bestseller 2009 Liberty defined
50 essential issues that affect our
freedom one that Ron Paul recommends if
you're picking up one of his books and
the school revolution came out last year
you've been watching book TV on c-span -
Ron Paul has been our guest